Oh
[Music]
okay well I thought this time that I
would actually cover some of the
biblical stories so and hopefully a
number of them as I said last time I'm
going to go through this while as fast
as I am able to I want to do it as
completed job as possible and of course
the probability that I'll get through
the entire Bible is very low but we'll
get through a lot of the major stories
in the beginning of it and that's a good
start and then you know assuming that
this all goes well then maybe I'll try
to do the same thing again either in the
fall or next year so assuming I'm that
everything is still working out properly
next year it's a long ways away all
right so I guess we'll start so last
week I talked to you about a line in the
New Testament that was from John and it
was a line that was designed to parallel
the opening of Genesis and it's it's a
really important line and I thought I
would re-emphasize it because the Bible
is a book that's been written forward
and backwards in time in some sense like
most books because if you write a book
of course when you get to the end if
you're the writer you can adjust the
beginning and so on so it has this odd
it has this appearance of linearity but
it really it isn't linear it's like
you're God in some sense standing
outside of time that's your book and you
can play with time anywhere along it and
the people who put the book together or
the books together took full advantage
of that and and and that makes the story
it gives the story odd parallels in in
many many places in a very large number
of places and this is one of the major
parallels at least from the perspective
of the Christian interpretation of the
Bible which of course includes the New
Testament and so there's this strange
idea that Christ was the same factor
or force that God used at the beginning
of time to speak habitable order into
being and that's a very very strange
idea you know it's not it's not
something that can be just easily
dismissed as superstition partly because
it's so strange it doesn't it doesn't
even fit the definition of like a
superstitious belief it's it's a
dreamlike belief in some sense and what
I what I see many of the ideas in the
Bible as is is these dreamlike ideas
that that under not lie are our
normative cognition and that constitute
the ground from which are more
articulate articulated and and explicit
ideas have emerged and this one's so
complicated this idea is so complicated
that it's still mostly embedded in
dreamlike form but it seems to have
something to do with the primacy of
consciousness and this is one of the
biggest issues regarding the structure
of reality as far as I can tell because
everyone from physicists to
neurobiologists debates this there's
there's the the stumbling block for a
purely objective view of the world seems
to me to be consciousness and
consciousness has all sorts of strange
properties for example it isn't obvious
what constitutes time or at least
duration in the absence of consciousness
and it isn't also easy to understand
what constitutes being in the absence of
consciousness because it seems to be the
case well if a movie is running and
there's no one to watch it I know it
sounds like the tree and the forest
idea but it's it's not that idea at all
if a movie is watching is running and no
one's watching it in what sense is can
you say that there's even a movie
running because the movie seems to be
the experience of the movie not the
objective elements of the movie and
there's something about the world at
least insofar as we're in it as human
beings that is dependent on conscious
experience of the world now of course
you can take consciousness out of the
world and say well if none of us were
here if there was no such thing at
consciousness then the cosmos would
continue running the way it is running
but of course it depends on what exactly
you mean by the cosmos when you make a
statement like that because there's
something about the subjective
perience of reality that gives it
reality or at least that's one way of
looking at it and since we're all pretty
enamored of our own consciousness as
although they're painful because they
define our being it's not unreasonable
to give consciousness a kind of
metaphysical primacy now and it's deeper
than that you know deeper idea than that
because there are physicists and they're
not trivial physicists like like John
Wheeler who believes that in some sense
consciousness plays a constitutive role
in transforming the chaotic potential of
being into the actuality of being he
actually thinks about it he's not alive
anymore but he actually thought about it
as as playing a constitutive role you
know and then from the neurobiological
perspective or from the scientific
perspective it's not consciousness is
not something we understand I don't
think we understand it at all it's
something we can't get a handle on with
our fundamental materialist philosophy
and I don't know why that is it's quite
frustrating if you're a scientist but it
isn't clear to me that we've made any
progress whatsoever in understanding
consciousness even though what we've
been trying to understand it for
hundreds of years and even though
psychologists and neurobiologist and so
forth have really like put a lot of
effort into understanding consciousness
from a scientific perspective in the
last 50 years so anyways what it seems
to me is the idea that that God used the
word to to extract order out of
habitable order out of chaos at the
beginning of time which is roughly the
right way of thinking about it seems to
me deeply allied with the idea that what
it is that we do as human beings is is
encounter something like a formless and
potential chaos I mean we're not
omniscient obviously and we can't just
do whatever we want but we encounter a
formless and chaotic potential that's
always what we're grappling with and
somehow we use our consciousness to give
that form and this is how people act
like if you look at how they regard
themselves it's how they act because you
say things to people like well you
should live up to your potential when
you make a case that there's something
about a person that's more than what is
that yet could be if only they
participated in the process properly
and everyone knows what that means and
no one acts like a mystery has been
uttered when you say that and you know
you can see a situation in your own life
that's full of potential you're often
extremely excited when you encounter
something that's full of potential
because what you see is something that
could be you see a future beckoning for
you that could be if only you interacted
with it properly and it activates your
nervous system right in a very basic way
and we even understand how that happens
to the degree that we understand how the
nervous system works because the systems
that mediate positive emotion which are
governed roughly by dopa by the
neurochemical dopamine and which have
their roots way down in the ancient
hypothalamus a very very archaic and and
fundamental part of the brain it that
responds to potential which is the
possibility of accruing something new
and valuable it responds to potential
with active movement forward and
engagement and so we're engaged in the
world as potential and looks like
consciousness does that and so there's
this idea that this is the main idea
that I think is being put forth in
Genesis one it's something like and you
see this in mythology like from from
what I've been able to gather there's
always three causal elements that make
up being at the bottom of world
mythology and one is the formless
potential that makes up being once it's
interacted with and that's generally
given a feminine nature and I think
that's because it's like the source from
which all things emerge and rise it's
something like that it's more
complicated than that but it's something
like that and then there's some kind of
interpretive structure that has to
grapple with that formless potential and
that's I think that's the sort of thing
that was alluded to by Immanuel Conklin
when he was criticizing the notion that
all of our information comes from sense
data which would be the pure empirical
perspective right because when you
encounter the world you encounter it
with a cognitive structure that already
has shape and so it's already in you
this structure and without that a priori
structure you wouldn't be able to take
the formless potential and give it
structure and I think that's something
it's a can in some way to the idea of
God the Father and I'll try to develop
that idea more it's it's the it's the
notion that there's something
in all of us that transcends all of us
that's deeply structural that's part of
this ancient while I would say
evolutionary and cultural process that
enables us to grapple with the formless
potential and bring forth reality
roughly speaking and then there's the
final element and that element seems to
be something like consciousness itself
the consciousness that actually in
here's in the individual so it's not
only that you have a structure it's that
the structure has the capacity for
action in the world and it's like it's
your this your the spirit that gives the
dead structure life it's something like
that and as far as I can tell the
Trinitarian notion that characterizes
Christianity is something like well
formless potential which is never given
a the status of a deity in Christianity
and then the notion that there's an a
priori interpretive structure that's a
consequence of our ancient existence as
beings it goes back as far in time as
you can go the notion of a structure and
then the idea of a consciousness that
that is the is the tool of that
structure and that interacts with the
world and gives it and gives it reality
and that's the word as far as I can tell
and so the notion is is that there's a
father and that's the structure and
there's a son that's transcendent that
characterizes consciousness itself and
that it's the son the speaking of the
son that is the active principle that
turns chaos into order and god it's such
a sophisticated ideas as far as I'm
concerned because well there's something
about it that's at least predominately
accurate because you do have an
interpretive structure and you couldn't
understand anything without it your very
body is an interpretive structure right
it's been crafted over let's say three
billion years of evolution without that
you wouldn't be able to perceive
anything and it's taken a lot of death
and struggle and tragedy to produce you
the thing that's capable of encountering
this immense chaos that surrounds us and
to transform it into habitable order and
then there's the idea - of course it's
deeply embedded in the first chapters of
Genesis which is a staggering idea you
know and and certainly not one that's
likely that human beings were made in
the M
of God both male and female were made in
the image of God and that's of course a
very difficult thing to understand
partly because the God that's referred
to in the in those chapters has a kind
of polytheistic element although it's an
element that's moving rapidly towards a
unified monotheism but it's not also
obvious to me why people would come up
with that concept because I don't really
think that when we think about each
other we immediately think God like you
know the notion that every single human
being regardless of their peculiarities
and strangeness --is and sins and crimes
and all of that has something divine in
them that needs to be regarded with
respect and that plays an integral role
at least an analogy an analogous role in
the creation of habitable order out of
chaos that's a magnificent remarkable
crazy idea and yet we developed it and I
do firmly believe that it sits at the
base of our legal system I think it is
the cornerstone of our legal system
that's the notion that everyone is equal
before God which is of course a
completely that's such a strange idea
it's very difficult to understand how
anybody could have ever come up with
that idea because the manifold
differences between people are so so
obvious and so evident that you could
say the natural way of viewing someone
is or human beings is in this extremely
hierarchical manner where some people
are contemptible and and and easily
brushed off as pointless and
pathological and and without value
whatsoever and all the power accrues to
a certain tiny you know aristocratic
minority at the top but if you look at
the way that the idea of the individual
sovereignty developed it's clear that it
unfolded over thousands and perhaps ten
thousands of years before it became
something firmly fixed in the
imagination that each individual had
something of transcendent value about
them and man I tell you we dispense with
that idea at our serious peril and so
and if you're going to take that idea
seriously then which you do because you
act it out because otherwise you
wouldn't be law abiding citizens right
you act that idea out it's it's it's
it's firmly shared by by everyone who
Ochs in a civilized manner the question
is why in the world do you believe it
assuming that you believe what you act
out which i think is a really good way
of fundamentally defining belief so all
right so so that's the sort of ideas
that there's this this god of tradition
and structure that's that's God the
Father who uses the Sun which is more of
an active force and and primarily
something that's verbal which I also
think is extremely interesting because
it's associated not with thought
precisely but with speech and I think
the reason for that is is that there's
something to speech that's more than
mere thought and I think part of the
reason for that is that speech is a
public utterance and at least in
principle speech is something that's
shaped by the existence of of everywhere
of everyone else at least across time
because when you speak you your speeches
is put forward in the world as a causal
element and it's also subject to
criticism and and and cooperation and
mutual shaping and so there's an idea
here too that speech is that that the
cognitive processes that bring habitable
reality out of out of uninhabitable
chaos have this collective and public
element which which is part of the
reason by the way that an advocate of
free speech let's say above all because
I don't think although it is the case
for example in the Canadian Bill of
Rights that every single right has equal
value that's the theory it's an idiotic
theory because it's absolutely
impossible for a large set of race to
have absolutely equal standards statuses
that cannot happen there's no way that
that can never work but that is the
legal judgment but I think it's a huge
mistake because free speech has this
while this divine quality let's say that
you can't escape from because it's the
thing that manufactures everything else
you know it's and so and I do think that
the the dream that you could think of as
encapsulated in the stories in Genesis
is is the dream by which human beings
dreamed up the idea that we would now
consider consciousness because you know
it took us a long time to figure out the
word consciousness it's not like it's
bloody obvious
it knows how many thousands of years or
who knows what struggles we had to
undertake to abstract out something like
consciousness and how we had to
represent that dramatically say or
symbolically or in a dreamlike fashion
before we could actually formulate the
term and and localize that to some
degree in people it's very sophisticated
so so John makes the case that well
there's there's an emanation of God or
an element of God the transcendent
consciousness it's something like that
that acts directly and in a sort of
living way with the with the underlying
potential of the world and I think that
that's phenomenologically accurate and I
do think that that's the way we regard
our lives because you know when you
think about it too we tend to think that
what you encounter when you're looking
at the world is the material world but
that isn't how you act you do act as if
you're in a place of potential and also
in a place of potential that you can
actually transform which is also
something extraordinarily strange you
know because we do treat each other as
if we're capable of bringing new forms
into the world in some permanent manner
right and we treat each other as if we
have free choice and free will and
perhaps we don't but it's certainly the
case that societies that are predicated
on the idea that we don't don't do very
well and societies that are predicated
on the idea that we do seem to do a lot
better
Plus people tend to get very annoyed at
you if you treat them like they're
automatons that lack freewill there's
something that people find very I would
say constraining slave-like about that
even you know that that's a demand that
you don't have actual autonomy and even
worse that you're not responsible for
your choices it's an insult to someone
to suggest to them that they're not
responsible for their choices you know
you usually to do that to someone from a
legal perspective you have to argue
something like diminished capacity right
well you're mentally ill or you don't
have the intellectual capacity or or or
you were or you were addled by some
substance or you had a brain injury or
something and that's why you're not
responsible for your actions otherwise
part of the respect that you get
to another human being is the assumption
that they're responsible for their
actions and some of that can be well if
you do something bad then you're
responsible for it but part of that too
is that if you do something good you're
also responsible for that and that also
seems necessary because I mean do you
really I mean it's got to be more
annoying than anything else you can
imagine to strive virtuously let's say
to produce something of extreme value
and then to be treated as if that was a
mere deterministic outcome and that your
your actual choices have nothing to do
with that I mean people find that sort
of thing extraordinarily punishing and
so I'm willing to you know I mean I know
that there are debates about all these
things and debates about free will and
debates about the nature of
consciousness but I'm trying to take a
clearer look at how people act and how
they want to be treated and then to
trace it back to these old ideas to see
if there's some if there's some
metaphysical let's say metaphysical
connection so all right so here's how
the here's how the book opens in the
beginning God created the heavens and
the earth the earth was without form and
void and darkness was over the face of
the deep and the Spirit of God was
hovering over the face of the waters now
this is a hard this is a hard what would
you call narrative section to get a
handle on because in order to understand
it properly you have to actually look
behind it so there are a lot of pieces
of old stories in the Old Testament that
flesh out the meaning of these lines and
I can I can give you a quick overview of
it one of the ideas that lurks
underneath these lines although you
can't tell because it's in English you
have to look at the original languages
and of course I don't speak the original
languages so I've had to use secondary
sources too bad for me but the the the
without form and void and the deep idea
you see that's associated with this
notion of endless deep potential so for
example the words that are
use to represent without form and void
or something like well one is toll I'm
going to get this partly wrong toll who
elbow who and another one is tailed and
it's important to know this because
those words are associated with an early
mess earlier Mesopotamian word which is
Tiamat and timeout was a dragon-like
creature who represented the salt water
and and timeout had a husband named AB
so and timeout adapts who were sort of
locked together and kind of a sexual
embrace and it was that locking together
of time at a nap sue and I would say
that's potential and order something
like that or chaos in order they were
locked together and it was that union of
chaos and order that gave rise in the
old Mesopotamian myth which is the Anu
male ish to the to the two being to the
old gods first and then eventually as
creation progressed to human beings
themselves and so there's this idea
lurking underneath this these initial
lines that God is akin to that which
confronts the unknown and carves it into
pieces and makes the world out of its
pieces and the thing that it confronts
is something like a well it's something
like a predatory reptile or something
like a dragon or it's something like a
serpent and I think part of the reason
for that and this this is this is a very
deep and ancient idea is that this is
where it gets so complicated to do the
translation is partly that is how human
beings created our world like we went
out beyond the confines of our safe
spaces let's say our space our safe
space is defined by by the tree or
defined by the fire and we actively
voyaged outward to the places that we
were afraid of and didn't understand and
conquer and conquered and encountered
things out there like like ant like
literally animals like mammoths and
snakes and predators of all sorts and it
was as a consequence of that active
brave engagement with the domain of what
we did not understand the terrifying
domain of what we did not understand
that the world in fact was generated and
that idea lurks be plea inside that the
opening lines of of genesis and it's and
it's a profound idea in my estimation
and i think
see I think also that the way our brains
are structured and this is something
that I'm going to try to develop more
today is that the ancient circuits that
our ancestors used to deal with the
space beyond which they had already
explored that would be home territory
that so that's that unknown territory
that's that's characterized by promise
because there are new things out there
but also by intense danger right because
we're prey animals especially millions
of years ago when we were very young we
had to go out there and encounter things
that were terribly dangerous and there
was a kind of let's say paternal courage
that went along with that and it was
that the spirit of paternal courage that
enabled the conquering of the unknown
and there's no difference between the
conquering of the unknown and the
creation of habitable order and the
thing is is that as our cognitive
faculties have developed to the point
where we're capable of very high levels
of abstraction the underlying biological
architecture has remained the same and
so I don't think that it's too much to
say at all that the the circuits that
you that engage you for example when
you're having an argument about
something fundamental with someone that
you love and so you're trying to
structure the world around you jointly
to create a habitable space that you can
both exist within you're using the same
circuits the extracted version you're
using the same circuits that our archaic
ancestors would have used when they went
out into the unknown itself to encounter
beasts and and and predators and and
geographical unknowns it's the same
circuit it's just that we do it
abstractly now instead of concretely but
of course it has to be the same circuit
because evolution evolution Ares is a
very conservative force and what else
would it be and this is also why I think
it's so easy for us to demonize those
people who are enemies because our
enemies confront us with what we don't
want to with what we don't want to see
and they and because of that our first
response is to use snake circuit or
snake detection circuitry on them and
that accounts for our capacity almost
immediate capacity to demonize and and
there's a reason for that it's not a
trivial thing first of all it's a very
fast respond
and second of all it's a response that
has worked for a very very very long
time and so you know one of the variants
of the hero and I would consider a
variant of the hero a like a fragment of
the picture of God is is the heroic
warrior who slays the enemy right and of
course that's not precisely a
politically correct representation of
the hero in modern times and well in no
wonder but it's still something that you
go watch in movies all the time and
admire right it's it's like this one of
the most how many plots are there
romance and adventure that's about it
and most of the adventure genre is well
there's some enemy that's lurking in
some form it could be human it could be
alien and someone rises up to go and
confront it maintain order you know it's
like there's no getting away from that
story and and if you don't have that in
your own life then you play a video game
where that's happening or you watch a
movie where that's happening you read a
book where that's happening and it
captures you even if you're atheistic
and your only religion is star wars you
know and and it's still well really
really right it really it still captures
your imagination and you act like
someone who's possessed by religious
fervor when you line up for three days
to be the first one into the theater you
know and all the while claiming that
you're atheistic to the core it's like
okay so this this without form and void
is this chaotic and it said it's hard
thing that it's a hard thing to get a
grip on you know what exactly this means
but I can give you another kind of
example of how you would experience the
formless chaos of potential in your own
lives and and even how the order that
you currently inhabit can dissolve into
that and you know in Dante's Inferno
when he outlined the levels of Hell so
Dante was trying to get to the bottom of
what constituted evil really in this
representation so it's a work of
psychology and he's thinking well there
are various ways to behave reprehensibly
but there's a hierarchy of reprehensible
behavior and there's something
absolutely the worst at the bottom and
and
Daunte believe that it was betrayal and
and i think that's right because you
know one of the things that enables a
long-term cooperation peaceful
cooperation between people is trust and
i would also say that trust is the
fundamental natural resource there's
been some very good books written on the
economic utility of trust for example in
societies where the default economic
presupposition between trading partners
is trust tend to be rich even if they
don't have any natural resources and you
can see that for example with what
happened with ebay which I think was a
kind of miracle because what should have
happened with eBay was that you sent me
junk and I sent you a check that bounced
right and that was the end of eBay but
right right exactly but that isn't what
happened like the default the default
transaction on eBay was so honest that
the brokers you could hire brokers to
begin with I can't remember what they
were called exactly but you could pay
someone a fee so that they would
guarantee the transaction so you know
you wouldn't send me junk and I'd
actually send you a payment and we'd pay
10 percent for someone to guarantee that
the default trade was so honest that
those things vanished right away and so
that meant that all this frozen capital
roughly speaking which were all the junk
that people had lying around that
someone else might want instantly became
money and the only reason that worked
was because people trusted one another
and so Trust is an unbelievably powerful
economic force may be the most powerful
economic force anyways if you have a
relationship with someone it's
predicated on trust and part of the
reason for that is that Trust is what
enables us to look at each other without
running away screaming and what I mean
by that is that if I trust you then I
don't have to take into account how
complicated you are because you're
horribly complicated to know I think
chimpanzee full of snakes that's what a
human being is and as long as you'll do
what you say you'll do then I can take
you at your word and your word
simplifies you and you can take me at my
word and my word simplifies you and then
we can act like we understand each other
even though we don't but then if that
trust is betrayed then all the snakes
come forth very very rapidly and so all
of you I suspect have been
trade one way or another and so what
happens if you're in a relationship with
someone and you trust them then you make
certain assumptions about the past and
you make certain assumptions about the
present and you make certain assumptions
about the future and everything's stable
and so you're standing on solid ground
and the chaos it's like you're standing
on thin ice the chaos is hidden the
shark beneath the waves isn't there
you're safe you're in the lifeboat but
then if the person betrays you like if
you're in an intimate relationship and
the person has an affair and you find
out about it then then you think one
moment you're one place right you're
where everything is secure because
you've predicated your perception of the
world on the axiom of trust and the next
second really the next second you're in
a completely different place and not
only is that place different right now
the place you were years ago is
different and the place you're going to
be in the future years hence is
different and so all of that certainty
that strange certainty that you inhabit
can collapse into incredible complexity
and you say well if someone betrays you
you think well okay who were you because
you weren't who I thought you were and I
thought I knew you
but I didn't know you at all and I never
knew you and so all the things we did
together those weren't the things that I
thought were happening something else
was happening and you're you or someone
else and that means I'm someone else
because I thought I knew what was going
on and clearly I don't I'm some sort of
blind sucker or the or the victim of a
psychopath or someone who's so naive
that they can barely live and I don't
understand anything about human beings
and they don't understand anything about
myself and I have no idea where I am now
I thought it was at home but I'm not I'm
in a house and it's full of strangers
and I don't know what I'm going to do
tomorrow or next week or next year it's
like all of that certainty that
habitable certainty it collapses right
back into the potential from which it
emerged and that's a terrifying thing
that's a journey to the underworld from
a mythological perspective and that is
really something worth knowing because
you know journeys to the underworld are
extraordinarily common in mythological
stories and you know like The Hobbit
going out to find a Smaug the dragon and
and get the gold as a journey into the
underworld and journeys to the
underworld how
and all the time and modern people don't
understand what the Wonderworld is
except that we've all been there and we
go there all the time and we go there
every time the solidity and stability of
the world that we've erected at least
partly through our speech is shattered
because while some sort of snake appears
that's another way of thinking about it
that it's a really good way of thinking
about it because you know no matter how
carefully you construct a little
habitable area that surround you there's
always something you didn't take into
account and there's always something
that can pop up its head and do you in
and make you aware of your mortality and
and age you for that matter or even kill
you and that's the permanent that's the
permanent situation of life which is
part of the reason why I think the story
of Adam and Eve for example is
archetypal it's because we do inhabit
walled gardens right because a walled
garden is half structure Society and
half nature that's what a walled garden
is and a walled garden is a place of
paradise and warmth and and and and and
and love and and and sustenance but it's
also the place where something can pop
up at any moment and knock you out of it
and I think part of the reason that that
story exists at the beginning of this
collection of books is because it
explains the eternal situation of human
beings we're always in that situation
we're in a walled garden or we bloody
well hope we are but there's always a
snake and then it's even worse because
if there is a snake or exactly the sort
of creatures who are going to do nothing
but go and interact with that state the
second that we can manage it you know
it's it's definitely the case that if
you want a human being to muck around
with something the best thing to do is
to tell them not ever to do it have
anything to do with it which is of
course something you know if you have
teenagers or even children or or if you
know anything about yourself or your
partner so these stories are trying to
express what you might describe as an
unchanging transcendent reality you know
it's it's something like what's common
across all human experience across all
time and that's what young essentially
meant by an archetype and you could say
well you know we tend
think that what we see with our senses
is real and of course that's true but
what we see with our senses is what's
real that worked at the timeframe that
we exist in right and so we see things
that we can touch and pick up we see
tools essentially that are useful for
our moment-to-moment activities we don't
see the structures of eternity
especially not the abstract structures
of eternity we have to imagine those
with our imagination and that's partly
what these stories are doing they're
saying well there's there's forms of
stability that transcend our capacity to
observe which is hardly surprising we
know that if we're scientists right
because we're always abstracting out
things that we can't immediately observe
but there are meta physical or moral
realities or phenomenological realities
that have the same nature that you can't
see them in your life by observing them
with your senses but you can imagine
them with your imagination and though
sometimes the things that you imagine
with your imagination are more real than
the things that you see numbers are like
that for example and there's endless
examples of that and I would say well
this is also a good way of thinking
about fiction because a good work of
fiction is more real than the stories
from which it was derived otherwise it
has no staying power right it's
distilled reality even though in some
sense it never happened it's like well
it depends on what you mean by happened
you know it's a it's a pattern that
repeats in many many places with
variation you extract out the central
pattern it's it's the pattern purely
never existed in any specific form but
the fact that you pulled a pattern out
from all those exemplars means that he's
extracted something real and I think the
reason that the the story of Adam and
Eve which we'll talk about in quite a
bit of detail today has it has been
immune to being forgotten is because it
says things about the nature of the
human condition that are always true it
can give you another brief example you
know like people have a lot of guilt you
know there's a line of social psychology
that claims that most people feel that
they're better than other people
like I just don't buy that that isn't
what I've seen in my life and maybe it's
I'm bit biased because I'm a clinical
psychologist and I see
more people who are overtly suffering
maybe then people do in general although
I'm not so sure about that you know
because you don't have to scratch very
far beneath the surface of most people's
lives before you find something truly
tragic and I don't mean the sort of
tragedy that you whine about I mean you
know your mother has Alzheimer's or your
best friend committed suicide or you
have a close relative with cancer you
have a sick child or you know there's
something wrong with you because almost
everyone has at least one really
terrible thing wrong with them and if
you don't hey you will so you know so
know that that so so that that tragic
sense of being is there with people all
the time and and and it's also the case
that not in my experience like I rarely
meet someone who says hey you know I'm
doing everything I possibly can I'm a
hell of a guy and I can't see how I
could possibly improve you know you meet
you meet someone like that you think
their narcissistic write would end
you're right and but but most people
don't feel that way they feel like they
could do a hell of a lot better than
they are and they're quite acutely aware
of their faults and they don't feel that
they're what they should be and you see
what happens in the story of Adam and
Eve as well as that when people become
self conscious at least that's how it
looks to me they get thrown out of
paradise and then they're in history and
history is a place where there's pain in
childbirth and where you're dominated by
your mate and where you have to toil
like mad like no other animal because
you're aware of the future you have to
work and sacrifice the joys of the
present for the future constantly and
you know you're going to die and you
have all that weight on you and to me
again that's just how can anything be
more true than that that's just as far
as I can tell that's just how it is
for unless you're naive beyond
comprehension there's something about
your life that that that is echoed in in
that representation and why it is that I
mean we're such strange creatures
because we don't seem to really fit into
being in some sense and that's also
what's expressed in the notion of the
fall we the existentialist said well
people feel like they have a debt that
they have to pay off to existence for
the for the crime of their for the crime
of the
being something like that and maybe it's
because we are acutely aware that we
have to offer something of value to the
people around us so that they can
tolerate us you know well we're going
about our business but it seems deeper
than that it's that human beings seem to
exist in a post cataclysmic world and
that's exactly also what's represented
in Genesis it's very interesting because
you know there's in the out of an EVE
story there's two there's two
catastrophes essentially there's the
catastrophe that occurs went out of an
EVE wake up which we'll talk about in
detail and become self conscious and
know that they're naked that and their
eyes are open right so that that's the
terminology that's used and to have your
eyes open means to have an an increment
in consciousness essentially because
eyes are associated with consciousness
for human beings because we're intensely
visual animals and so the metaphor of
having your eyes open means it's the
same as the metaphor of coming to
consciousness and as soon as Adam and
Eve come to consciousness they realize
they're naked and you know the classic
interpretation of that is that it has
something to do with sexual sin and I
don't I don't believe that I don't
believe that that's what it means
although they're elements about that
that are relevant it's more that to
realize that you're naked it's like
you're you know if you dream that you're
naked and on a stage in front of people
that's not a sexual dream man unless
you're some kind of strange
exhibitionist right it's if you want to
cover yourself up and get the hell off
that stage as fast as possible and so to
be naked in front of a crowd is to have
everyone it's to have the judgement of
the social world focused on your
self-evident inadequacies and that makes
people self-conscious and that's that's
a real human state it's associated with
neuroticism in the big five trade model
but people don't like that at all they
don't like having their fragility and
vulnerability exposed to the group it's
one of the two major fears of people
because one is social humiliation and
the other is something like mortality
and death and like your typical
agoraphobic
for example gets to have both those
fears at the same time because she
usually as she tends to believe she's
going to have a very spectacular and
exhibitionistic heart attack in a
public place and make a terrible fool of
herself while she's dying so and then
that's a good example of the two
archetypal fears that characterize
characterized human beings so so to me
and I said that I tried to approach
these stories as if I didn't know what
they were about because that seemed
right to me because their mysteries
their everything about them is
mysterious and why we have them is
mysterious and what the hell you're all
doing here is mysterious you know
listening to this lecture and so and
reading Hume because you and Carl Jung
was very very helpful in this because he
he faced these stories with the
beginner's mind and presumed there was
something to him that he didn't
understand given that they were at the
very bloody bottom of our civilization
you know which is historically perfectly
clear and that they came out of the
midst of time and he wasn't satisfied
with the idea that a Freudian idea that
God was just the father or the Marxist
idea that religion was the opiate of the
masses it's like if religion was the
opiate of the masses then communism was
the methamphetamine of the masses I can
tell you that so
so you know you've been betrayed by
someone and so you fall into that
underworld of doubt about everything and
it's a serious place to be in that
underworld a because not only do you not
know where you came from or who you are
where you're going that's bad enough
so that's the underworld itself but
there's a subdivision of the underworld
like the worst suburb which is I think
what hell is essentially from the
metaphysical perspective because you
know if someone really cuts you off at
the knees especially if they do it in a
malevolent way and and if you're going
to be betrayed and you really want to be
betrayed properly you want to be
betrayed by someone who's really out to
hurt you you know they just weren't
being stupid they were like after you
for whatever reason and then that's also
you plunged into that underworld space
and that's also when you start to nurse
feelings of resentment and aggrievement
and murder and homicide and even worse
you know because if people are betrayed
enough they start they start to obsess
about the utility of being itself and
perhaps go to places that no one would
ever want to go if they were in the
right mind and to and to develop a nurse
fantasies of the ultimate revenge and
that's a horrible place to be and that's
hell as far as I can tell and that's why
hell has always been a suburb of the
underworld because if if you get plunged
into a situation that you don't
understand and things are not good for
you anymore it's one step from being
completely confused it's only one step
from being completely confused to being
completely outraged and resentful and
then it's only one step from there to
really looking for revenge and that can
take you places that well that that
merely to imagine properly can be
traumatic and I've seen that happen with
people many times and I think that
anybody who uses their imagination on
themselves can see how that happens
because I don't imagine there's a single
person in the room that hasn't nursed
fairly intense fantasies of revenge at
least at one point in their life and
usually you know for what appear to be
good reasons it's no picnic to get
betrayed that's for sure that can shake
your faith in being but if it shakes it
so badly that you turn against being
itself that's certainly no solution
that's for sure all it does is make
everything that's bad even worse
so okay now so and God said let there be
light and there was light and God saw
that the light was good and God
separated the light from the darkness
and so that's that's another that's
another fundamental separation right
light and darkness those are those are
in some sense the two fundamental two of
the fundamental elements of our
conscious being because of course when
it's light we're awake and conscious
because we're diurnal animals and when
it's night well then we're asleep and so
our existence is bounded by light and
darkness we're up and alert when it's
light and that's partly because we're
highly visual animals right unlike most
animals because most animals you smell
we we use vision we're very strange that
way and vision is associated with
enlightenment and illumination and with
the breaking of the dawn with the coming
of the new day and all of that so and so
for light to be created is associated in
some sense with the emergence of
conscious being and so that's another
echo of that notion and they're the the
particular phrasing of the of the story
also is important because it's again
that God fed right so that's the use of
that word and that's the active element
of the structure that gives rise to the
gives order to chaos it's something like
that so it's it's like the spirit of the
structure manifests itself and produces
the fundamental divisions of experience
that's what's being presented here and
God separated the light from the
darkness he called the light day and the
darkness he called night and again again
the fact that things are named is also
very important so you see this later
with Adam because God gives Adam the job
of naming all the animals and it's sort
of like the animals don't actually exist
in some sense till they're named and
that's that's another indication of the
authors of the Bible's attempt to come
to terms with the fact that our
cognitive faculties and our ability to
speak have something to do with the way
that we task chaotic potential into
actuality right because we can't we
can't really get a grip on something
before we have a name for it which is
like for example you all have names and
everything that you encounter has to
have a name because before it has a name
it's just kind of
part of the blurry background in
something like that and you could say it
exists before it has a name but and
that's true but it's also true that it
doesn't exist before it has a name
because as soon as you give something a
name its nature changes and you've
transformed it into something that's not
so much mere potential anymore but it's
at least on its way to being actuality
it's on its way to being a tool and so
the act of naming is repeated
continually in the first chapters of the
Bible and the reason for that is this
continued emphasis on the importance of
consciousness and conscious articulation
and speech you know when speech is
really something that does separate us
in an important way from animals you
know like we haven't got very far
teaching animals how to speak the best
we've managed so far as some parrots
right there's gray African parrot there
is one of them that got up to about a
four-year-old level and that's
mind-boggling because like how big is
the brain of a parrot it's like that big
and that bloody thing could talk and so
that shows you how much we know about
brains but I know they're small and all
that but and we tried teaching
chimpanzees to talk and they could kind
of get somewhere with sign language
especially if you started when they were
young but they don't have the capacity
for language like we do and they were
never able to really pass it on to the
to the next generation which is
obviously a critical element of really
having that ability so human beings
we've used our linguistic capacity to
parse up the world in a new way and to
conceptualize it in a new way and you
know you can say that we're just like
ants on this little trivial planet out
on the edge of one of a hundred million
galaxies and that what's happening here
has no cosmic significance but that's an
arbitrary that's an arbitrary
proposition you know I mean we're very
complicated things and whatever's going
on on this planet has to do with
conscious reality and the
transformations of consciousness for all
we know might be the most important
things that happen everywhere there's no
reason to consider consciousness a
trivial phenomena I mean it's taken
three and a half billion years for you
to develop the brain that you've
developed and you and human beings are
amazing creatures I mean
just a casual walk through YouTube and
all those crazy kids that climb cranes
and do that what's that that ya parkour
man that stuff's unbelievable you know I
mean human beings are crazy crazy
animals there's almost nothing we can't
do and I'm very loath to assume that the
transformations of consciousness that
are described in the early in the early
stories in in the biblical accounts are
somehow cosmically trivial it doesn't
strike me that way and it's certainly
not self-evident and even if they are
cosmically trivial whatever that means
the rocks don't care what you think well
who cares what the rocks think first
they don't think so I don't see why
that's exactly relevant but even if even
if it's all the same to the cosmos which
is something that I doubt it's certainly
not just all the same to you you know
because your consciousness has a quality
and it matters the Heidegger for example
who's a philosopher who who's writing
sort of influenced me post-talk because
i recreated some of the things that he
had talked about in the 30s before I
knew much about him but one of the
things that Heidegger said was that the
fundamental element of human being of
human phenomenology was care he said
that that's the basic essence of your
being is that you care about things you
know and that's necessary that either
negatively or positively right you to
not care about something or to hate it
is still to be involved in care and so
even if the cosmos itself is is neutral
with regards to our existence we're not
and we're the only things that we know
of that are conscious and so while we
might as well go with that and there's
no reason see I can't help but think
that the constant attempts by people to
trivialize the nature of their own
consciousness has a dark side I'm a
psychoanalyst and so I always think that
way it's like well first of all if
you're if you as a being don't matter
then you don't have to do anything it's
a great justification for total lack of
responsibility and that that really
twigs something for me because you know
people who are bent let's say or
vengeful or angry are always looking for
a reason why they don't have to be
responsible for anything
it's a lot easier and so the notion that
consciousness is trivial immediately
allows you to wander down that path and
so I'm skeptical of those claims and I
also think that there's a deep hatred of
humanity that underlies those claims as
well and I read my youtube comments
sometimes you know and I've always been
I've always been
annoyed that you know because I've heard
like sort of radical clueless
environmentalists say things like planet
would be better off without people on it
which is something that like you just
cannot say that that if you say that and
listen to yourself
you should like go to a monastery for
like three years and never say a word
and have a shower every 10 minutes until
you've learned your lesson properly you
know you can't adhere a more genocide
'el phrase than that you know and of
course you always do it in a display of
your care for the world it's like well
if we just didn't have any people it's
like well we'll just line them all up
and shoot them with machine guns no it's
really sickening it's appalling and
there's a hatred for humanity that's at
the bottom of it and I mean you can kind
of understand why because we're messy
and you know we don't clean up after
ourselves and you know we're like raping
the rain forests and that sort of thing
but I do have some sympathy for people
because you know we're we're hell on
mother nature but she certainly returns
the favor so and that's a good thing to
remember you know a lot of what we're
doing is just bloody well trying to
exist with a relative minimum of pain
and we're doing our best to get you know
to get as good at doing that as fast as
we can and that's not an easy thing
there are lots of us and like life is
bloody complicated and the other thing
that happens too is again if you scratch
just beneath the surface of people and
this is something that's always you know
to me is being a kind of miracle is if
you talk to someone they're out doing
their job and maybe they're doing a good
job at it like some emergency room nurse
you know it's God there's a job for you
or maybe they work in palliative care
you know and you talk to them and you
find out they've got like four as I said
before serious problems in their family
and maybe they're diabetic to boot and
yet they haul themselves out of bed in
the morning and go take care of dying
people it's like good god people deserve
a bit of respect for struggling forward
and not always trying to make the planet
a worse play
when they're beset on all sides
constantly by you know unending series
of tragedy you think we could have a
little bit of sympathy for ourselves as
a consequence of that it's like we're
not all like rapacious greedy monsters
who are bent on just devouring
everything in our path you know it's a
little bit more complicated than that
so all right anyway so so well so let's
go to the next part of this here mmm-hmm
all right so God said let there be an
expanse in the midst of the waters and
let it separate the waters from the
waters and God made the expanse and
separated the waters that were under the
expanse from the waters that were above
the expanse and it was so and God called
the expanse heaven and there was evening
and there was morning the second day
well to understand that because what how
did that doesn't make any sense at all
really so I think I told you a little
bit about this before so the the the
world that's being created in this
particular account is a phenomenological
world there's a disc of land because if
you go out in a field and look around
you're on a disk of labs that's pretty
obvious and then there's a dome on top
of it it's more or less held up by the
mountains and rain comes down so there's
water above the dome because where else
would the rain come from and underneath
the ground there's fresh water you can
drill down and find out and then around
out there's salt water and so that's the
world and it's kind of an empirical
world because if you're a child and you
just go out in the field and you look at
the world that's sort of what it would
be like and so that's the world that's
being created and so one of the things
that is worth thinking about this is
something Carl Jung was very interested
in is that these old descriptions are
half geographical and half empirical so
sort of based on observation and half
psychological
so one of the things young was
interested in for example was astrology
but mostly for a psychological reason
because you know they're obviously there
are stars up on the dome and then when
you look at the stars you can imagine
the shapes of the stars and that helps
you orient yourself because as soon as
you can see shapes and the stars then
you can recognize the constellations and
you can orient yourself at night but
then the constellations become God's say
and the gods turn into a drama and so
and the drama comes from
then it's the projection of imagination
and so when Young was analyzing
astrology he was in that analyzing
psychology because he saw the
astrological narrative as the projection
of the human imagination onto the cosmos
and so when he was analyzing astrology
who was analyzing psychology and that
the same thing is the case with these
stories is that the world they they
describe is only it's not the natural
world like a scientist would describe it
because these people weren't scientists
they didn't have the technology in the
tool it was it was the way they were for
them it was the world for us it's the
way they saw the world and so we're
looking at the way they saw the world
and a lot of that psychology and we
share that psychology to a large degree
with those people so in this is
psychology but it's interesting to know
what the geographical substrate is so
that you can kind understand the stories
and I like this picture because that's
it's great from a psychological
perspective it's a very famous picture
you know so basically what you have here
is the world as we know it and there's
the dome with the Sun and the moon on it
and the stars and then if you look
outside what you know well then you're
out into this cosmic space right and
that's those are like the wheels of the
planets and the music of the spheres and
that's the ever-present Explorer who's
gone beyond the domain that he can
understand and is peering out into the
unknown as such and it's a psychological
picture it's like because you do know
some things and then outside of that
there are things you don't know and when
you're feeling brave you put a foot or
two out where you don't understand like
because there's frontier everywhere
right and if you're if you're feeling
heroic and you want to do something for
the world and you want to expand what
you understand you poke your head
through what you know and you take a
look at the that's the at whatever
structure is out there and you know he's
pretty smart because most of them is
still where it's safe and I would say
that's a good that's a good thing
because if you jump right out there well
then maybe you fall off the edge of the
earth and I wouldn't precisely recommend
that especially if you do it
accidentally and to me this is a
recreation of the of the Taoist yin-yang
symbol you know with the with the white
Paisley here and that's what
no in the dark paisley serpents really
there and the right place to be is right
on the line between them because you're
sort of got one foot where you
understand that gives you security and
then you know but it's kind of dull
because hey you know everything that's
going on there and that is what people
are like they don't want just security
Dostoyevsky said that in notes from the
underground a great great book and you
know he said I love this it was his
early critic criticism of the notion of
a political utopia he said look if you
gave people everything they wanted they
had nothing to eat but take and nothing
to do but sit in warm pools and busy
themselves with the continuation of the
species that was his his lives that the
first thing they would do well maybe
after the first week was like gold kind
of half insane and smash everything up
just so that something that they didn't
expect would happen so that they'd have
something interesting to do and it's so
right because you know that the utopian
notion that if you just had all the
material stuff you wanted that you'd
you'd be well what would you be what
what would you do would you just sit in
the couch and watch TV I mean you did
you'd be I don't know why you'd be
cutting yourself just for entertainment
in no time slot you know and that's the
sort of thing that people do and so
we're not adapted for security in Utopia
were adapted for a certain amount of
security because you know we are
vulnerable but mostly we want to have
one foot out where we don't know what
the hell is going on because that's
where your alert and alive and tense and
with it and and you know I think I
believe this and I believe it actually
has something to do with the hemispheric
structure of your of your of the
physiology of your brain is it because
the right hemisphere looks roughly
adapted to what you don't know and the
left hemisphere and this is a very this
is an oversimplification but a useful
one is adapted to the world that you do
know and the right place for you to be
is halfway between them because then you
can tell that that's what's so cool and
this tells you that this is actually
reality that's manifesting itself to you
you know that sense of active engagement
you have in the world when things are
working well for you you know where
you're where you should be at the right
time
you're alert and on top of things and
engaged and you don't have much of a
sense of time and the sense of the
tragedy of life sort of recedes and
that's when your that's when you've got
one foot when it's where it's secure in
one foot out in the unknown and your
brain signals to you that you're in the
right place by making what you're doing
meaningful and that sense of meaning is
actually a neuro physiological signal
that you've got the forces of the cosmos
properly balanced in your being at that
moment and that's why it feels so good
and then well what else could it
possibly be I mean you know our brain is
capable of looking beyond our vision
that's what it's for and that sense of
engagement there's no reason to assume
that that's anything but a real signal
and you can reduce it you could say well
the problem with being where you know
only is that you don't know everything
and that's going to be a problem in the
future and the problem with being where
you know nothing is that's just too much
man like you know you go into panic mode
and because anything can happen there
and you can't handle it so you've got to
mediate between those two things you
want to be secure enough so that your
physiology isn't revving out of control
and you want to be out there in the
unknown enough so that you keep updating
yourself constantly constantly
constantly and that's that's the place
where information flow is maximized and
you know that because that's where you
are when you're having a really
interesting conversation with someone or
you're gripped by a book or you're
really into a movie or maybe something
that you do as a you know apart from
your work or maybe even in your work
you're into it and that's because you
are in the right place at the right time
and your whole nervous system is
signaling that to you and I would say
that's the sort of place that you should
be all the time of course you can't be
because no one's perfect but it's that's
that's the recreation of paradise on
earth it's something like it because you
are in the right place at the right time
when that is happening subject to
certain what would you say restrictions
that we can talk about later well that's
what this guy is doing and and that's I
would say akin to the action that God is
taking when he's transforming the chaos
of potential into habitable being and
it's the sort of thing that human beings
supposed to act out and God said let the
waters under heaven be gathered together
into one place and let the dry land
appear and it was so God called the dry
land earth and the waters that were
gathered together he called seas and God
saw that it was good well that's an
interesting thing too because you know
there's this display written by a German
named Gupta I can never say that
properly it's johann van goe t-80 and I
can't say it but he wrote this play
called Faust and he wrote one part of it
when he was quite young and then Klaus -
when he was quite old and he has a
character in there Mestas tov ELISA
message da fleece is the devil and he
actually has the devil explaining
himself twice basically using the same
words which which I really like it was
very profound and basically Goethe's
Memphis dolly says you know he's the
adversary of the word that's a good way
of putting it because that's how it
works out mythologically he's the figure
behind the snake in the Garden of Eden
which is something we'll talk about more
but he has a he has a sophisticated
philosophy he's not just some random
troublemaker he's got a he's got a deep
philosophy and his philosophy is quite
straightforward and it's compelling it's
compelling and people are gripped by it
quite often far more often than they
think his philosophy is well look around
at the world like Ivan karamakov in The
Brothers Karamazov when he's trying to
disabuse his younger brother of being a
Christian monk Memphis awfully says well
look at the world I mean all we look
around the world it's nothing but a
bloodbath
it's just suffering everywhere
everything eats everything and people
die terribly and and they're cruel to
one another and the whole mass is
nothing but a constant hall of terrible
carnage and ruin and and and and and and
wreck he says it should be better if it
was never existed at all and that's a
very interesting that's a very very
interesting idea and I do believe and
I've seen this in people many times but
in the depths of despair especially when
you've been betrayed for example and you
wander into the wrong subdivision of the
underworld that
something that comes to mind if you know
you have a very sick child for example
or maybe your whole family is suffering
as whole families do sometimes an idea
is going to come to you it's like good
God who put this mess together and is it
really worth it is it really worth the
suffering suicidal people you know they
say no they say no enough of this you
know and you have to be pushed a long
way generally speaking before you'll
actually commit suicide you have to be
in very very desperate straits but your
answer under those conditions is that
being is such that it would be better if
it had never been and that's a very I
think I think it's a very it's a
terrible philosophy I believe because I
think what happens if you act it out is
that you make the very things that led
you to despair far worse and I can't see
that if it's reasonable to draw a
logical conclusion that suffering should
justifies your desire to make being end
that the answer to that can't be to
produce more suffering
it just doesn't make sense and my
observation has been that people who act
out the Memphis to--they liyan
philosophy inevitably make suffering far
worse and so and then that raises the
other specter of well do they want being
just diseased or they just out for
bloody revenge at every at any cost and
my conclusion has always been that is
that the mask is well being shouldn't
exist because it's too terrible but the
true motivation is I'm going to make
everyone suffer as much as I possibly
can before I say goodbye to this place
if you read the writings of people like
the kids who showed up the Columbine
High School they'll tell you exactly
that that's precisely and exactly what
they conclude it and then act it out
so anyways but in this God says that it
was good and I thought about that a lot
is like because the question is
something like well is it something
better than nothing because that's a
really good question you know and I
thought about two things in relationship
to that and one is one is well maybe it
depends on how it is that you are right
because it could be that there are ways
of being in the world to justify the
world and their ways of being in the
world that makes the world unbearable
and I believe that the narrative that
runs through the biblical stories is
precisely a dialogue between those two
types of BA and the optimistic part of
the story is that being requires
limitation and suffering there's no
escape from that but there are modes of
being that allow that to be perhaps even
more than tolerable perhaps there are
modes of being that allow that to be
good and it's a straight and narrow road
it's a very difficult road to tread so
so I think well that that's possible you
know I'm not an optimist by nature and
but that's that's one of the things that
I've conceptualized and read about that
I actually find plausible because it's
certainly the case everyone knows this
that there are ways that you can act and
make things worse
everyone knows that and so if that's the
case there has to be the opposite right
there has to be ways that you could act
that make things better and obviously
you can act in ways that make things
really way worse and so the question is
well are there ways that you can act and
make things really much better and I
think that's the question is can we have
our cake and eat it too
can we have the being that requires
limitation and suffering and also
simultaneously transcend that by our
mode of being and I believe that the
biblical stories and then perhaps not
only the biblical stories but the
biblical stories are the human imagine
one of the human imaginations best
attempt to address and answer that
question that's what the entire story is
about so the first of it is the
catastrophe of the collapse of
self-consciousness and the entrance of
humanity into history and the rest of it
is okay now we're in history now we know
that we're going to die we know about
our mortality we're conscious of our own
being is there a mode of acting in the
world that allows that to be justifiable
or maybe even more that allows that to
be triumphant and then I would also say
maybe it's worth finding out you know
that that's the other thing that's so
interesting because you've got this
short time on earth and there's lots of
things that are very very difficult to
contend with and and you have the
problem of tolerating yourself even in
all your insufficiency and one of the
things that seems to me to be the case
is that if you adopt a sufficiently
profound mode of being if you attempt to
do that then the mere act of lifting up
that weight is enough to justify
the fact that your insufficient and
mortal and and bound by tragedy and I
believe that and I believe people
believe that because if you watch how
people act they look for people they
admire and they do admire people right
it's a natural it's a natural phenomena
you see it starting with children be
children admire and then they imitate
and we look to people who seem to be
able to bear the burden of being in a
heroic manner and there's something
inside of us that calls to that and it
makes us want to to mimic that and to
follow it and I think that that's I
think that's the deepest and most
profound of instincts and I think it's
right and even if you're not so
convinced on the positive end you know
because it's more difficult to be
convinced of the positive you can
certainly be convinced on the negative
end because there are ways of being that
are so brutal and so reprehensible that
merely to read about them is enough to
traumatize you and I think that if
you're a person who hasn't lost their
soul completely you can't help but
encounter stories like that and shudder
away from them and you know Alexander
Solzhenitsyn
who who was the person who did most
announce the absolute horrors of
communist totalitarianism said that he
believed that the Nuremberg judgments
were the most important event of the
20th century and that was the judgment
at the end of World War two that there
were certain actions that no one was to
undertake no matter what their cultural
background was because they were let's
say crimes against humanity that there
was such a thing as universal evil and
you can debate that you know I mean and
people certainly have but the problem is
is if you debate that then you have to
say that there are conditions under
which the sorts of things that happen
say in the concentration camps which
would be the gassing of children after
their torture and and their their
forcible removal from their parents and
all the terrible things that went along
with that that that's just okay it's
just an opinion it's just something that
happened and there are circumstances
under which that's justifiable if
there's no transcendent good and evil
underneath that argument it's only a
matter of practicality and and and it
seems to me that that's that's not the
right conclusion to draw
that's how it seems to me and that's
what the Solzhenitsyn concluded when he
looked at the Nuremberg trials so the
notion that the notion that it was good
well even if you don't believe that and
you know because maybe it's not as good
as it could be I would say it's
incumbent on you as someone who
participates in the process of a
furthering creation to act as if it
could be good at least and to further
that with with all of your efforts
partly because what the hell else do you
have to do that could possibly be better
than that that could possibly justify
your existence more than that and you
know perfectly well if you if you have
any sense at all if you think clearly
about it at all is that that's what you
want to see in everyone else you know
it's you're you're desperate and maybe
you're cynical and now and then someone
appears that acts at least momentarily
like a light in the darkness enough
lifts your spirit up and gives you a
little bit of hope and maybe helps you
continue on well that's obviously a call
to being if it's a statement from your
old soul that says well there's
something about that that's how you
should be and maybe then well we get a
chance to to participate in what is good
I thought too you know well we'll leave
that for a little later and God said let
the earth sprout vegetation plants
yielding seed and fruit trees bearing
fruit in which is their seed each
according to its kind on the earth and
it was so and the earth brought forth
vegetation plants yielding seed
according to their own kind and trees
bearing fruit in which is their seed
each according to its kind and God saw
that it was good and there was evening
and there was morning the third day I
like that that's you see it's
interesting these old pictures say
because if you look here you got you got
this halo around God's head and you've
got to split again between night and
darkness and gods right on the on the
border between the two and that's the
Sun right that's what that's what a halo
is halo is the Sun or the moon sometimes
it's like a coin you know you have the
Queen's head on the coin and that's the
queen on the moon and it's silver and
it's a symbol of value because of course
the Queen is sovereign and
the moon is the sovereign of the night
sky and and gold of course is the Sun
and gold is pure because it doesn't mix
with other metals and it shines like the
Sun so it partakes of the Sun and god
partakes of the Sun because there's
something about whatever he represents
that's associated with consciousness and
illumination and enlightenment
it's that force of illumination
enlightenment that's it's right on the
border between these two sets of
phenomena and that's that's kind of what
that picture is trying to present and so
you know it's a metaphor that's one way
of thinking about it but it does again
allude to the underlying idea that
there's something about consciousness
that's integral to to being itself God
said let there be lights in the expanse
of the heavens to separate the day from
the night and let them be for signs and
for seasons and for days and for years
that's a that's a remarkable bit of a
bit of writing there too because you
just think about how bloody long it took
our caveman ancestors to look at the
night sky and start to figure out that
there were repeating patterns across
years that enabled them to mark the
seasons I mean I just can't imagine how
they figured that out it's that degree
of careful observation that it took and
I mean we know people figure that out a
long time ago because ah you know those
great megalithic monuments like
Stonehenge seem to be astronomical
observatories essentially and you see
the same thing with the pyramids I mean
people were looking at the damn sky
trying to figure out looking at God you
know because that's kind of what you're
doing when you're looking at the night
sky trying to figure out the regularity
and order in the universe and that's all
compacted into this little light you
know and let them be for signs and for
seasons to be oriented by the Stars
amazing and that let them be lights in
the expanse of heavens to give light
upon the earth and it was so and God
made the two great lights the greater
light to rule the day and the lesser
light to rule the night and the Stars
and God set them in the expanse of
heavens to give light on the earth to
rule over the day and over the night and
so there's an idea of sovereignty there
too right that that that there's an
analogy between the ruler and the and
the heavenly bodies that that light up
the that light up the darkness
essentially and that's a really
interesting idea too because it took us
a long time to come to terms with as I
mentioned last week to come to term
with the idea of sovereignty itself and
to decide what constituted valid power
it's not power it's not power its
authority and competence and not power
it's not dominance either it's more
sophisticated than that because the
people that you want to rule aren't
people who have power because power just
means I can hurt you and you can't hurt
me back that's that's not that that's
not what you need from a ruler even
though it devolves into that from time
to time what you want is the kind of
wisdom that illuminates the darkness and
to associate the sovereign with with the
heavenly kings of the light is a
perfectly reasonable thing to do from a
metaphoric perspective and that's an
ancient ancient idea you know and
another example of how we're grounded in
a dream that God set them in the expanse
of heavens to give light on the earth to
rule over the day in the night and to
separate the light from the darkness and
God saw that it was good another
emphasis on the fact that it was better
that there was something than nothing
and you know maybe you could maybe you
could consider that the Declaration of
the cosmos is something like well it's
better that there's something than
nothing and well how do you know that
and I guess the answer to that is that
there's something instead of nothing and
I know that that's not proof but but
it's still a remarkable fact that it
happens to be the case and no one does
know why that is so maybe we should go
along with it and see what we can do
with it you know and see how we could
make it better because we certainly
could if we were if we were really
committed to it and we shook our
resentment and our our anger and our
hatred and I know there's reason for all
of that because people do suffer
terribly but you know god only knows
what being could be like if we all
contributed it contributed to it to the
best of our ability god only knows what
we could conquer and what sort of
magnificent cities we could produce and
what things we could we could eradicate
from from from the suffering of the
world
and there was you know there's this guy
I read about this is amazing and I don't
remember his name but he he found out
about this worm that was called the
guinea worm and guinea worm is a really
horrible thing and you can look it up if
you want but I'll tell you a little bit
about it even though it's very
distasteful so I get any worm is a
parasite that lives in Africa and it
burrows under your skin and it's quite
long it's about that long and it's you
know about that wide and so it'll burrow
underneath your leg and then it's in
there you know and maybe it pokes its
little head out a hole which is one of
its delightful tendencies and then if
you want to pull it out it breaks right
because obviously because otherwise you
just pull it out it would be dead and so
it doesn't like that so it just breaks
off and many many people had this
horrible disease you know and it's well
you can you can't imagine what that
would be like because you're a part of
the 1% and you live in North America and
thank God for that but you know just a
little imagine you don't even want to
think about it let alone have it and he
went to Africa and wiped the damn thing
out it's like great you know it seems to
me the planets a lot better off without
any guinea worms on it even though
that's like guinea worm genocide talk
I'm still you know pretty happy about it
and so that was that was one guy who
thought well we don't need these things
and yeah well fair enough you know and
yeah well so good for him like you know
I mean he can die thinking that the
world's a better place than it was when
he first popped out and so so good for
that that NASA I think that's a good
that's a good aim you know I think is to
think that when you're on your deathbed
you can look back and think well there's
a little less suffering in the world
from here on out than there would be if
I had never existed and that's a lot
better than the opposite because it's
certainly possible say if you're Stalin
to ensure that there's a hell of a lot
more suffering in the world than there
would have been if you hadn't lived and
we perfectly well know that people can
manage that and that many many people
try to do nothing but in that but manage
precisely that so and it's hard for me
not to think about that as some sort of
metaphysical evil and I think it's the
right way to look at it and there was
evening and there was morning.the 4th
day so yeah you have the Sun here and
then the moon here as far as I can tell
yeah yeah actually I think this is the
moon over here but but so yeah that's
part of the Sistine Chapel which is you
know an absolutely remarkable and then
they know part of the reason - and the
part of the reason I'm teaching about
these biblical stories is because you
know I'm thinking because the humanities
have be decimated so badly and again I
think that has mostly to do with
resentment and hatred more than anything
else but I don't really think that you
can get a grip on the humanities and
what they have to offer without knowing
the biblical stories because they're the
they're the dream out of which the
humanities emerge and so unless you have
that background knowledge that dream
then there's all sorts of things that
are utterly profound that don't open
themselves up to you and Dante's Inferno
would be one of those and Milton's
Paradise Lost which is an absolutely
amazing piece of work I mean Milton
wrote it because he wanted to justify
the ways of God to man you know what an
ambition that is and I mean he was
serious about that he took the problem
seriously it's like it's the Memphis
dethalian problem is that well this is a
rough business that were involved in and
you know maybe maybe we should just give
it up I think the world the whole world
I think was deciding that in the 1980s
when we were deciding whether we going
to engage in the ultimate nuclear
catastrophe you know and we were very
very close to that a number of times and
I think it was a collective decision in
some sense on the part of humanity that
we might as well keep the whole awful
game going rather than just demolish it
but um but you know Milton he wrote
Paradise Lost - it's a dream again it's
a dream trying to explain the nature of
being and the nature of evil and you
can't crack the damn thing without
knowing the underlying stories and
that's really too bad because it's
utterly profound and the reason you need
profound things as far as I can tell you
need profound knowledge is because life
is actually a profound problem for
everyone I mean you can shelter back and
live a very conservative existence and
look like more power to you I understand
why you would do that but it doesn't
stop you from having to face the
ultimate questions of life right there
right there in everyone's face and at
least at some point your life and it
would be better if you could I think if
you could confront them full-on and
to deal with them properly and to be a
beacon of strength as a consequence of
vadas and it's and I think that wisdom
that's what the humanities are supposed
to teach his wisdom and wisdom is what
enables you to deal honorably with the
tragedy of life and I think you I can't
see how you could think that that was a
bad idea because they're going to be
times when you're in an emergency room
and you know prone to panic and to and
to cry and to break down and to and to
collapse and to be of no use to anyone
around you and that's not the right way
to be it's the right way to be in a
situation like that is to be strong and
reliable and I don't think you can do
that without being wise and you can't be
wise without putting yourself together
and without knowing something about
where you came from and what you're like
and that that's history and the
humanities and so this isn't optional
it's it's it's more necessary the man
does not live by bread alone and that's
exactly the issue here so you see these
magnificent works you know I mean
there's a there's it's not like
Michelangelo thought of this literally
you know he was a genius for god sake
and he's trying to get at something and
and he's trying to get at the profundity
of human culture I suppose that's why
you have this patriarchal figure here
and the cosmic role that consciousness
and tradition plays in being itself and
and it's ennobling and you know you
think people religious or not people
hundreds of millions of people come from
all over the world to Rome and go
through this little tiny chapel to look
at this it's something in it that
everyone needs to see you know it's not
just beauty it's more than beauty it's
it's that which feeds the soul and
everyone feels that even if they can't
explain it so and God said let the
waters swarm with swarms of living
creatures and let birds fly above the
earth across the expanse of the heavens
so God created the great sea creatures
and every living creature that moves
with which the waters swarm according to
their kinds and every winged bird
according to its kind and God saw that
it was good and God blessed them saying
be fruitful and multiply and fill the
waters in the seas and that birds
multiply on the earth and there was
evening and there was morning the fifth
day and God said let the earth bring
forth living creatures according to
their kinds livestock and creeping
beasts creeping things and beasts of the
earth
according to their kinds and it was so
and God made the beasts of the earth
according to their kinds and the
livestock according to their kinds and
everything that creeps on the ground
according to its kind kind right that's
kin right and to be kind is to treat
others as if they're your kin and so
according to its kind and God saw that
it was good that continually continually
represented over and over God said
that's the thing that calls being into
existence and God said it was good and
that's the fundamental judgment about
the nature of reality and you know one
of the things that happens in the in the
translation in the movement let's say
from the Old Testament to the New
Testament is God is obviously blessing
creation in the beginning of this story
and then you have Old Testament God and
like don't mess around with him right
because he'll give you a good smiting if
you get out of line there's no doubt
about that and he's kind of an arbitrary
character and you know lots of modern
people think well how could you believe
in a God like that and it's like when I
read that I think well that the Old
Testament people that is how they
thought they thought you better look the
hell out because life is really
difficult and if you step out line
you're going to get flattened and God
doesn't care in some sense whether you
approve of him it's like what the hell
does that have to do with anything
obviously you don't approve it's like
you better pay attention though because
otherwise you're going to be in real
trouble and not there's real wisdom and
that Nietzsche thought that it need to
really admire the Old Testament that's a
work of literature because he thought
that the representation of the divine
let's say as a representation of the
essential nature of being was
extraordinarily accurate in its
arbitrary and often cruel nature you
know it wasn't following a morality that
human beings could really understand as
moral he thought that was very realistic
and I like that interpretation but what
happens in the New Testament is quite
interesting because there's an
insistence all of a sudden in the New
Testament that you're supposed to act
towards God as if he's nothing but good
and that's such a strange thing because
you know you look at the world it you
think we're yeah really just good a well
the cancer and the earthquakes is kind
of hard to fit into that picture and you
know the terrible things that happen to
children and all about is very difficult
to square with the notion of a good God
obviously
but then there's the other underlying
idea is that if you act in that manner
it makes it more likely to be true it's
something like that and so it's that I
would consider that in some sense and
active both courage and faith it's like
you're going to make the case like God
makes at the beginning of the Bible that
being is in fact good now you can't see
it because well you get to see all the
things about it that aren't so good
that's not the point
it's a metaphysical presupposition
something like that it's a it's a
decision to act that way I'm going to
act as if being is good and to further
that and then the implicit idea is well
there isn't anything that there isn't
any way that you can make things work
out better than to do that and so
there's a courageous element to it which
i think is also expressed to some degree
in the idea of Christ's like voluntary
sacrifice of his own life his
presupposition was something like I'm
going to act as if God is good and I'm
going to play that out right to the end
and now that becomes something like a
divine pattern and I believe there's
wisdom in that because again I most of
the time that I've been wrestling with
this sort of thing I've always been
looking at the opposite I haven't been
studying good I've been studying evil
because evil is easier to believe
especially after the 20th century it's
like I think you have to be you have to
be blind not to think about the things
that happened in the 20th century as
evil and then some of the things that
happen we're so brutal it is just
absolutely unimaginable and well unless
you imagine it and and it's it's it's
right there it's part of the historical
record it's it and then I think well if
there's something that that's it's that
terrible it indicates as clearly as
anything can that there's also something
that's its opposite and that's whatever
it is that the farthest away possible
from that outcome now that doesn't mean
we can exactly say what it is because
it's easier to grip in some sense what
it means to torture and break and hurt
and then not to be able to conceptualize
so clearly how you would have to act if
you were acting in the exact opposite
manner but at least it implies that it
exists
and I see that pattern being laid out in
this dreamlike manner in the New
Testament and it has something to do
with well it has something to do and
this is for sure with the voluntary
acceptance of mortality because of
course that's the poisoned apple right
the fact that everybody looks forward
into the future to know that you're
finite and so is everything that you
love and it's very difficult for that
not to poison your existence and well
there's no getting out of it as far as
we can tell but there might be something
like switching your attitude to it and
you could say well that's the price you
pay for being and the heroic thing to do
is to accept that and not even to accept
it grudgingly to say alright I'm going
to go along with that I'm going to
accept that and I'm going to act
nonetheless as if being is good and then
I'm going to see how things turn out
it's something like that and God saw
that it was good and so it's an act of
courage right there there's an act of
courage that's associated with that
transformation of attitude and even with
regards to the notion that the world is
good it's a courageous attitude
especially given that there's so much
evidence that makes that conclusion
difficult to continually draw but the
alternative seems to me to be far worse
so there's God again with the Sun behind
him because he's associated with the
solar consciousness and he's creating
all these strange wonderful creatures
and and you know it's a and people say
well you know the idea of God as a an
old man in the sky let's say that's
primitive it's much more better to think
about it as a much more better Jesus
anyways it's more sophisticated to think
to think of the divine essence as a
disembodied spirit or something like
that but you know that's not so that's
not so obvious either because as I
already pointed out there isn't anything
that's more complicated than a human
being and and so the idea that the
divine is something that's at least as
complicated as a human being strikes me
as something that's actually quite
reasonable and I know it's a metaphor
although I don't know to what degree it
is a metaphor and it's also something
that's embodied and I really that's also
a very interesting notion
you know because it's become
increasingly obvious as we tried to do
such things as produce artificial
intelligence that it's very difficult to
produce an intelligence or perhaps a
consciousness that isn't embodied in
some manner it can't be just it can't be
just a spirit the spirit without form
and I think that's part of the reason to
why Christianity put so much emphasis at
the end of time on the resurrection of
the body because there's there's a
there's a drive in there to e Noble to
ennoble the idea of the body not just
the spirit the consciousness that floats
abstractly above the body but to say
that no you can't do that you can't just
shed that part of you that's heavy and
material so to speak and leave it behind
as if it's of no value you have to be
Noble and Noble that as well and that
idea is also linked to the note to the
representation of God as as a human
being and as a wise human being and as
something that's embodied and so at
least from the metaphorical perspective
I don't think it's reasonable just to to
brush your hands across it and say well
that's that's primitive because I don't
think it is I don't think it's primitive
at all and then God said let us make man
in our image after our likeness and it's
our because well this is a this is part
of the priestly story there's as I said
a number of sources for the Old
Testament and in the priestly version if
I remember correctly its Elohim that may
be wrong doesn't matter but the
precisely it doesn't matter because the
notion is is that the God who's in the
background of this story has a kind of
plurality of being right and it looks
like the idea of monotheism arose with
great difficulty across time because
there are lots of powers and the idea
that there's a power of powers was
something that it wasn't easy for people
to figure out you know in it because
what what constant across sources of
power or some kind of meta power but
it's hard to figure out what that is and
that's what's being represented by by
the movement as far as I can tell from
polytheism to monotheism it's it's the
first the observation that there are
powers that determine the destiny of
people at least in part that you
that you're subject to and then the idea
that there's something common across all
those powers that you can represent
partly say with the idea of the Sun
rising in the morning and fighting its
way out of the darkness at night and
that that's associated with
consciousness and sovereignty is very
very see one of the things that bothers
me about simple-minded atheism and I
would say the simple-minded atheism is
of the sort that regards these stories
as nothing but simple superstitions is
that it's very very poorly informed
because whatever these stories are
they're not merely simple superstitions
they weren't conjured up by some cabal
of priests to bamboozle the masses even
though they were used for that purposes
from time to time it's much much more
complicated than that they have a very
ancient lineage and they're tied
together with all sorts of other stories
and there's there's an emergent wisdom
in them and I think the right way to
view them is as the birthplace of
sophisticated philosophical ideas and so
you have to wrestle with these stories
you can't just and I said already that
I'm going to be as rational as I
possibly can in my discussion of these
stories and not refer to anything
metaphysical except when that's
absolutely necessary even though I don't
want to eliminate the possibility of a
metaphysical reality because I think
that's premature but but you have to
take the story seriously if you're going
to if you're if you're going to if
you're going to approach the problem
properly you can't just casually dismiss
them it's not appropriate and so so let
us make man in our image that's a very
interesting idea and like I said it's
not easy to understand how it was that
human beings came up with the idea that
us lowly creatures were so it with the
Mesopotamians for example and the Greeks
were like this to human beings weren't
godlike they were
the playthings of the gods right they
were they were just the gods just
tortured us for their amusement you know
love and hatred and anger and all those
powerful forces we were just
you're just playthings to the gods there
wasn't anything particularly divine
about us the notion that in some sense
we partake of the divine that's a
staggering idea and you don't want to
under underestimate the difficulty that
there was in abstracting that or the
utility of that idea for our current
mode of being
let them have dominion over the fish of
the sea and over the birds of the
heavens and over the livestock and all
the earth and over every creeping thing
that creeps on the earth so God created
man in his own image in the image of God
he created him male and female he
created them that's interesting because
there is more than one creation story in
Genesis and in this story males and
females are basically created at the
same time later Eve is extracted out of
Adam and we'll talk about that but not
here it's the two sexes are generated
simultaneously and they both carry
within them the divine stamp which is
very egalitarian and very appropriate
and I think unbelievably advanced that
that's what it looks like to me and God
blessed them well that's a good thing
and God said to them be fruitful and
multiply and fill the earth and subdue
it and have dominion over the fish of
the sea and over the birds of the
heavens and over every living thing that
moves on the earth and there's God
creating Adam and Eve and they're
looking pretty happy about the whole
thing and that's Michelangelo's famous
Sistine Chapel representation and
there's some cool things about this I
mean you got to wonder this this is a
side and I don't know if it's a credible
side but it's an interesting aside so
that's that's a form of credible what
the hell is God doing in this thing now
I mean what is this exactly and and so
there's been some interesting answers to
that and this is one of them so there
was a group of scientists about 20 years
ago that that were remarked on the
precise the precise analogy between this
structure and the brain bisected down
the middle and of course Michelangelo
was one of the first people who did
detailed dissections and so they felt
that that that Michelangelo had put God
inside the brain for some reason and
that seems to me to be associated with
the notion that there's you know there's
a there's an analogy or metaphorical
identity between the notion of whatever
God is and the structures that give rise
to consciousness and I think we really
underestimate the
degree to which consciousnesses is both
say miraculous and and not understood I
mean you know you you have what appears
to be an entirely material substrate yet
here you are aware itself aware and able
to generate the world merely in some
sense by looking at it it really is
remarkable and that consciousness is
dependent on on something that Wells up
from deep within that material substrate
that we don't understand at all it's
it's really a crazily remarkable thing
you know and you hear you hear a lot
about scientific reductionism but I'll
tell you something that's kind of
interesting in this it's a tangent to
you know the guy that discovered DNA I
think it was Watson and just walks in
and Crick but I don't remember who wrote
this book but one of them I don't
remember which one he believed the DNA
was so complicated that it had to come
from space he didn't believe it could
have possibly evolved on earth and so
like a lot of these people who are used
as exemplars of scientific reductionism
aren't like that at all when you
actually read what they had to say right
they they were very aware of the limits
of their own knowledge and I mean DNA is
something really quite spectacular Lee
remarkable it's an eternal substance
it's been around for a very long time
and the idea that we understand it is a
very stupid idea and I would say that I
would say that the same thing applies to
the brain like where we're scratching
away at the surface of something we
don't understand at all
so it's quite interesting I think that
and it maybe Michelangelo had enough
gall to do that it's certainly possible
I mean he had enough gall to do
dissections when the when the cost of
that was death you know he had this
robbed corpses essentially to go and do
it so he was he wasn't I would say not
particularly politically correct so so
that's kind of interesting and there's
another representation of the same thing
and that's a funny one I had to throw
that in I don't know how many of you
know this but there's there's there's
this joke in the atheistic atheist
community I think it might have be
started by Richard Dawkins but that
might be wrong that it was just as
reasonable to believe in the Flying
Spaghetti Monster as it was to believe
in God into that's a Flying Spaghetti
Monster by the way and and and so that's
that's called cuts by his noodly
appendage and anyways it's fine it's not
very sophisticated but it is funny so
and God blessed them and God said to
them be fruitful and multiply and fill
the earth and subdue it and have
dominion over the fish of the sea and
over the birds of the heaven and over
every living thing that moves on the
earth and God said behold I have given
you every plant yielding seed that is on
the face of all the earth and every tree
with seed in its fruit you shall have
them from for food and every beast of
the earth and every bird of the heavens
and to everything that creeps on the
earth everything that has the breath of
life I have given every green plant for
food and it was so and God saw
everything he had made and behold it was
very good and there was evening and
there was morning the sixth day thus the
heavens and the earth were finished and
all the host of them and on the seventh
day God finished his work that he had
done and he rested on the seventh day
from all his work that he had done so
God blessed the seventh day and made it
holy because on it God rested from all
his work that he had done in creation I
like that - you know one of the why did
a lot of counseling work with people who
were coaching work I guess with people
who were fairly spectacular ly
successful and they were usually
workaholics you know they're the sort of
people that were like they work 80 hours
a week non-stop
that's just what they were like and one
of the things we were always trying to
figure out was well how much should you
work because one answer is you just work
till you die right I mean he just
exhaust yourself and well that's not
that's not a good idea and then you have
to figure out why that isn't a good idea
it's got to be something like this is
that you don't want to do so much work
that the amount of work you do
interferes with the amount of work that
you could still do right because if you
work like mad for two weeks and then you
like you have to lie in a hospital bed
for a month that obviously isn't very
productive so you have to figure out how
much you can work diligently and then
how much you have to recuperate so that
you can get back up and work again and
you know that's people have basically
settled on something like this and given
it the divine imprimatur that that's one
way of thinking about it which is well
you can toil away for six days and no
wonder because you have to work but you
should rest at least one day out of
seven
otherwise well you don't appreciate life
that might be part of it and plus I
think it's more a matter of iterative
durability you know because one of the
things that defines morality is the
capacity to repeat something right so if
something is properly structured in a
moral manner then you can do it over and
over and over again without any
degeneration and so that's kind of like
a relationship if your relationship is
negotiated you can continue to negotiate
it and then you can have a relationship
that lasts for a long time you can do it
today and next week and next month the
next year you could maintain it across
time and this I would say is the wisdom
that's been a so that's been garnered
over god only knows what period of time
to say well look I mean even God needed
to take a break and appreciate what was
going on and it's not such a bad thing
for people to follow that that pattern
and that's a good thing for modern
people to know because we seem to be
even though you know we're very wealthy
by historical standards our capacity to
relax isn't exactly what it could be and
I think that's really hard on people
okay so I'm going to go over again the
idea of the attributes of God I talked
about that a little bit last week but I
want to return to it because I think
it's worth it's worth dwelling on a
little bit because we're trying to
figure out what it is that people were
trying to formulate when they were
formulating these representations and we
sort of come to the conclusion that
they're there there's an attempt to
abstract out the nature of power from
specific aspects of power and there's
some attempt to associate that with
consciousness as that which gives rise
to being itself and there's some attempt
to associate that consciousness with
something that has a cosmic quality
whatever that might mean and and it's a
statement that it has a cosmic quality
rather than rather than a discovery it's
a mere statement that there's that
there's something about consciousness
that has world generating significance
and also the implication that it's
associated with human beings as well
very and it's a very interesting set of
propositions and I don't believe that
they're simply refutable like it's a
perfectly coherent argument even though
it's primarily made metaphorically and
so then once again I want to build up
the
the framework of associations around the
idea of God one of the things that Freud
did when he was interpreting dreams and
it's quite useful you know so if someone
comes to me with a dream then I have
them tell me the whole dream and then I
get them to repeat it line by line and
then whenever they say a line and it
there's an object in it or a person or
something like that I ask them what that
makes them remember or what that thing
means to them or what comes to mind and
that's the associational technique and
it's predicated on the idea that your
memory works by association and you know
that if you're daydreaming you know you
go from one thing to another like a
conversation does and that you can take
an idea that's at the center of a web of
associations and by attracting the
associations you can kind of zero in on
what the idea might need and then you
expanded that by trying to he called it
to amplify the dream by thinking about
about narrative or literary or
mythological similarities that that
might be associated with the narrative
structure of the dream and and I think
often that can be unbelievably useful
you know and it's like the dream is an
idea that's trying to come to birth it's
partly formulated and then if you
discuss it and amplify it it's like you
can speed along its transformation into
a more articulated idea and the dream is
also something that because your brain
your mind is trying to with one foot in
the unknown it's trying to formulate
what's out there in the unknown and to
make it concrete but but it doesn't do
that in one fell swoop it doesn't just
take potential and turn it into two
articulated ideas it has to dream up
what's out there first projects its
imagination out there to get a handle on
what it might be it then that's
presented in the dream and if you
analyze the dream you can make it more
articulate and so that's what we're
going to do with the attributes of God
to build up the representational
structure a little bit so so the
hypothesis is that God is an abstracted
ideal formulated in large part to
dissociate the ideal from any particular
incarnation or man or ruler and the
underlying idea there too is that when
the ruler becomes the ideal the state
turns into the biblical Egypt and the
biblical Egypt is a tyranny
and so there's a very very solid idea in
the Old Testament that I think took
people god only knows how long to figure
out that if you transformed if you
confuse the notion of sovereign
sovereignty with the current sovereign
then your culture immediately
degenerated into totalitarian state and
turned to stone and that was deadly then
you were slaves and then the thing was
going to collapse as well like no matter
how big and grandiose as soon as the
ruler became the concrete incarnation of
the ideal there was no distinction
between the man and the divine notion of
the ideal then the society was doomed
and I think that that's a less I think
that's what I think that's true it's
just as simple as that and I think we
saw more than enough evidence of that in
the 20th century and we're certainly
seeing the same thing repeating itself
now when the ruler becomes the ideal the
state turns into the biblical Egypt and
the biblical Egypt is the archetypal
tyranny so what is God like well from
the Christian perspective there's three
elements one is seems to have something
to do with tradition and so that's God
the Father and that's partly the
embodiment I would say of the human
being because that's an ancient ancient
thing and it's also partly the
embodiment of the tradition of human
beings which is also a very ancient
thing and that's the structure as I said
it's the structure that consciousness
emerges from that enables us to grapple
with the unknown as such and then
there's there's the the intermediary
between that and and Christ say that's
the holy spirit that's that bird and
that's that's the spirit in a more
abstracted sense and I would say that's
probably as close as Christianity ever
got to the notion of consciousness as
such you know disembodied consciousness
something like that and then there's the
notion of the suffering individual and
and that's that's a very complicated
idea and it's something like in order
for so there's this idea an old idea and
I believe this was originally a Jewish
idea that a something with the
attributes of God omniscience
omnipresence and omnipotent lacks
something
so it's like a Zen koan it's a really
interesting idea what won the world can
something like that lack and the idea is
limitation so something that's
everything lacks limitation and that's
got that idea like when I first
encountered that just blew me away I
thought it was such a such a brilliant
brilliant realization that there are
advantages to not being able to do
things because partly because it gives
you something to do I suppose that's
that's a big part of it right is if you
had everything you wanted that at every
moment at your fingertips well that
that's there's there's nothing there's
no story and it's funny you know because
that happened to Superman you know the
the cartoon character by the 1980s he
could juggle planets and you could
bounce like hydrogen bombs off him and
be fine and it's like everyone got bored
because well what we're going to do to
Superman like you love a hydrogen bomb
atom and he just brushes it off and like
combs his hair and that's the end of
that and the whole cartoon series
basically died because he didn't have
any flaws there's no story without the
limitation and I think that's an
absolutely remarkable idea and so part
of the notion of Christ and this is
something that I puzzled over for a long
time and I learned a lot of this from
young is that there's IDN Christianity
that there's consciousness as such which
which in some sense is eternal it
stretches from the beginning of the time
to the end of time but it's this
abstracted notion but it lacks a certain
kind of reality because it's not
instantiated somewhere not it's not
instantiated in a specific time and
place in history and so the idea of the
Sun that the third part of the Trinity
or one of the three parts of the Trinity
is the notion that tradition and
consciousness as such also has to be
embedded in history in a particular time
in place and so there's the archetypal
embeddedness and that would be the
Incarnation and that's the perfect man
right who accepts his mortality and acts
in a virtuous manner but it's in a it's
a it's the archetypal story of every
individual as well and you know there's
a very strong strain in Christianity I
would say this is more pronounced in
Orthodox Christianity that the that the
purpose of that the proper path of life
is to take the tradition let's say and
the spirit that's associated with
consciousness as such and to act it out
in your life in your own personal life
in a manner that's analogous to the
manner in which Christ acted out in his
life and what that means in part is the
acceptance of the tragic preconditions
of existence and so that's partly
betrayal right betrayal by friends and
by family and by the state and it's
partly punishment for our sins that you
did not commit as well as the ones you
did commit and sometimes that's just a
relief but you know the arbitrary nature
of justice and also the fact of finitude
and the notion is is that your duty
let's say and the way to set things
right in the cosmos is to accept that as
a necessary precondition for being and
to act virtuously despite that and
that's a very very powerful idea as far
as I'm concerned and I'm also you know
the world is a weird place and I've seen
some very strange things in my life and
one of the things that I've seen is that
you know I've dealt with some people who
are very let's say that they weren't on
a good path let's put it that way and
one of the things that was really
interesting about being around people
like that it was like almost like they
were surrounded by a gravitational field
of sorts I'm speaking metaphorically
obviously and their worldview was so
warped and twisted that if you came
within contact of them you all of a
sudden started to play a part in their
drama and it was almost inevitable they
would maneuver and manipulate and
interpret in a way that made you into
the villain in their story no matter
what it was that you wanted to do and
unless you've encountered something like
that and many of you probably have you
don't know how powerful a pole that is
and so it's certainly possible that
someone can act in a like like like a
gravitational odd object and bend things
around them to fit their narrative
they're unhappy and tragic narratives
but I've seen the officer - you know
we're people who were aiming upward with
the best of their ability and because of
that they had a positive effect on the
people around them and and that that
that that and that ordered things around
them in profound ways and I think it's
an open question
the degree to which the cosmos would
order itself around you properly if you
got yourself together as much as you
could get yourself together like I mean
we know that things can go very very
badly wrong if you if you do things very
badly wrong there's no doubt about that
but the converse is also true if you
start to sort yourself out properly and
then you have a beneficial effect on
your family first of all that's going to
echo down the generations but it also
spreads out into the community and we
are networked together you know we're
not lit we're not associated linearly we
all affect each other and so it's an
open question the degree to which acting
out the notion of the notion that being
is good and the notion that you can
accept its limitations and that you
should still strive for virtue it's it's
an open question how profound effect
that would have on the structure of
reality if you really chose to act it
out and I've seen things as I said in my
life that indicate that I do believe
there's a metaphysical element to life
as well as the rational practical
element and I think there are times when
those two things come together and I've
seen that happen and so I don't think we
know the limits of virtue I don't think
we know what true virtue could bring
about if we if we aimed at it carefully
and practically and so the notion that
there's something divine about the
individual who accepts the conditions of
existence and still strives for the good
I think that that's a idea that's very
much worth paying attention to and I
think the fact that people have
considered that idea for at least 2,000
years quite seriously is also an
indication that there's there's at least
something to be thought about with in
relationship to that so that's kind of
the trinitarian idea same idea there and
you see this is it's interesting too
because you have here you have God the
Father essentially who's coming out of
this strange you see this isn't the sky
exactly and you see this very often in
these old pictures it's not exactly the
sky whatever the heaven was that that
the people believed in it's something
that's it's like the sky opens and
there's a dimension beyond the sky it's
something like that and I want to show
you this too just to show you that this
isn't only a Western conception you know
when it has something to do with mystic
experience because there's there's a bar
to satisfy it kind of looks like he has
a hat but that's not a hat that's a
whole bunch of bodhisattva's going back
to Eternity right and this hole in the
sky here is like a hole into time and
these things are recurring across time
it's the eternal recurrence of this of
this redemptive archetype and the sky
opens up and and you can see that thing
recurring and recurring and recurring
same ideas basically that's the blue
Buddha who's a healing who's a healing
entity sitting in a mandala which is
like a representation of paradise and
it's the same idea it's like reality
opens up and reveals this image of
perfection and so it's a well it's a
universal conception and and well I
think it's a representation of the
possibility of the metaphysical and the
physical coming together and in some
sort of in some sort of communication
it's something like that anyways and I
mean you have to remember that there's
absolutely no doubt that people have
metaphysical and religious experiences
that's an absolute fact you can induce
them chemically you can deduce them
electrochemically lots of people who
have epilepsy have epileptic prodromus
that are associated with divine
enlightenment so does the S key for
example he had he had epilepsy and that
was really I think one of the things
that made him a great author because and
Dostoyevsky would have this feeling that
he was going to have an epileptic
seizure and he said that the feeling for
him was that the world was opening up
and he was becoming more and more and
more enlightened and he was just on the
verge of grasping the essence of
existence and then he'd have an
epileptic seizure and for the subjective
feeling was that that much knowledge was
just too much for him to bear well you
know you can say well that was a
neurological abnormality and fine you
know but God he was Dostoyevsky you know
and so you can't just brush that off so
yeah well so that's the Trinitarian idea
fundamentally and if this notion here is
the notion that well the crosses crosses
a funny thing because the cross marks
the center you know and it's an X and
the X is the center of the world like
the X that the Cathedral is and it's the
center of the world it's where you are
because as a consciousness you're the
center of the world and that center of
the world is a place of betray
no and suffering in limitation that's
that's exactly what it is and the
question is well given that and given
the fact that you know it what the hell
are you supposed to do about it and what
that represents
I believe that's coil with that
representation implies is that you're
supposed to voluntarily accept that and
then move forward um well in good faith
and with courage that's the notion and
that you're supported you're supported
by your tradition and that's why you
need your tradition to that's why you
need to be embedded in your tradition
because without that without the support
let's say of your father and I mean that
both practically and metaphysically
without that behind you without the
knowledge of you as a both a biological
and the cultural creature without that
depth of knowledge you can't hey you
don't have the courage to do it because
you don't know what you are what you
could be and so without that because
you're a historical creature you know
what students ask me sometimes why study
history it's like well because history
is about you that's why it's like
history tells you who you are you can't
tell who you are because you only live a
little while how the hell can you figure
out who you are so you need all this
collected wisdom and all this dream like
information and all this mythology and
all this narrative to inform you about
what you are beyond what you see of
yourself and you know you're pummeled
down and people picked on you and
there's 50 things about you that are
horrible and you know you've got a
self-esteem problem you're sort of
hunched over and you've got all these
problems you know and so it's not easy
to see let's say the divinity that lurks
behind that and unless you're aware of
the heroic stories of the past and the
metaphysics of consciousness let's say I
don't think that you can have the
courage to regard yourself as the sort
of creature that can stand up underneath
that intense existential burden and move
forward in encourage and grace and of
course that's part of the reason that
I'm talking about these biblical stories
and it's nine-thirty so we're going to
have to stop
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so we're going to stop exactly at
10:00 tonight because that that's the
deal with the theater people and so and
besides I'll be out of anything
intelligent to say by that point
certainly so while it needs to go
through one story so that was good
[Applause]
[Music]
okay let's give everyone like to you
know just a few seconds to settle down
and and everyone who wants to leave can
leave so thank you for all for coming by
the way I'm constantly amazed at this
you know everybody comes and listens to
this because you know it's just well
strange let's put it that way so so far
it's been fun though so that's good okay
let's go I hope that works hi dr.
Pearson I was a raised Catholic and
anytime there was a bit of a an inherent
contradiction let's call it in the
document to the Bible it would be
referred to as a mystery and there's one
mystery I've always kind of wondered
about and it's very important to Genesis
how do you how do you deal with a
perfect God or the conception of a
perfect God who by nature is incapable
of an imperfect design sorry are
incapable of a perfect design so what I
mean by that is many religions present
for example good and evil as separate
deities that pre-existed simultaneously
what's interesting though Christianity
is that Lucifer the embodiment of evil
in the Christian religion is an
outgrowth of God and is sometimes Milton
for example presents him as a rebel
against his interpretation of God's
tyranny right another example you know
we had didn't touch on even today but in
Paradise a supposedly perfect Garden a
perfect design is infiltrated again by
that evil outgrowth of a so-called
perfect God so from a psychological
perspective do you think there's a
significance to this presentation of
perfection yet the contradictory flaws
that are sort of naturally part of that
perfection quote-unquote oh so good
that's a good simple question we're
starting good see young Carl young he
was kind of manichaean in his approach
and he tended towards thinking that evil
in some sense was a separate entity you
know and I thought about that for a long
time because there's a potency about
evil that just can't be brushed
way and I mean I mean this most
practically as I've said for people in
my clinical practice I've dealt with
many people who are touched by
malevolence and there's no other way of
stating it properly and this happens a
lot to people who have post-traumatic
stress disorder like they encountered
someone that wanted to hurt them for the
sake of hurting them you know it wasn't
some misunderstanding you can forget
about that it wasn't that at all and so
to to deny the reality of evil in some
sense I think is the ultimate in naivety
even though it's a word that you won't
hear used for example very often in
universities anymore but that I just
thought just I just can't understand
that at all but but I thought about that
a lot and and so I'm going to kind of
answer that question by hitting it
scattershot
the first thing is is that there's an
idea and that this happens in Milton
this cut that comes across in Milton
that distance from God is hell right
that hell doesn't actually have any I
know it's ambivalent in Milton but but
the fundamental claim seems to be that
the farther you get from God the more
it's hell and then there's another idea
that Milton's Satan who's Lucifer the
bringer of light right he's God's
highest angel gone most wrong and I kind
of think about him as the spirit of
rationality of intelligence it's not
because I'm not an admirer of
intelligence because hurray for
intelligence but one of the things that
that Milton seemed to cotton onto before
the rise of modern totalitarian States
was that intellect has the capacity to
fall in love with its own creations and
to elevate them to the highest place
which is basically a totalitarian claim
it's like what I know is everything that
needs to be known and if it was only
manifest in the world the world would
become a utopia and I also think that
we'll talk about this next week I also
think that that's the core idea behind
the Tower of Babel remember the Tower of
Babel is raised by human beings so that
the pinnacle will hit heaven and so it's
the idea that we can build a structure
that makes the transcendent unnecessary
and so ok so there's those two things
then there's there's an idea of free
will that's associated with it too and
it seems to me that in order for there
to be good there has to be evil and so I
I think the answer is something like
this is that in order for there to be
being there has to be limitation in
order for their good to be good there
has to be the possibility of evil I
think the right path is to exist such
that the possibility of evil remains
open but that you choose the good and I
don't think that evil per se is built
into the structure of the world I do
think that that's human I think that
evil is human and I think it's
understandable
I did a lecture that's online about the
distinction between evil and tragedy and
tragedy seems to be built into the
structure of the world and perhaps you
can blame God for that I mean it doesn't
seem to me that it's your fault that
there earthquakes for example but but it
is all not obvious to me either that
it's tragedy that takes the spirit out
of people I think that human beings are
actually equipped to deal with tragedy
but we're not equipped to deal with
malevolence that destroys people and so
I think that I think that metaphysically
speaking the world is structured so that
people have a choice between good and
evil and that so then the next question
is why do we have a choice and that
that's where my knowledge runs out I
don't I don't like the alchemists for
example speculated that and then the
Orthodox Christians also followed this
line of reasoning is that human beings
in some sense are furthering creation by
our actions and by our choices and I
think there's something to that it's
like it's like creation is unfinished in
some sense and that we're participating
in in moving it in whatever direction we
it is that we want to move it and part
of that is that we have freewill and
part of that is that we have the choice
between good and evil and that's also
it's all associated with with the
significance maybe the cosmic
significance of our lives and I blood
that strikes me as plausible and and I
think that the weight of responsibility
that people feel existentially is an
indication of that so that's about the
best I could do with that so and it
seems the way you're describing it it's
built into at least the text that you
presented because one of the other
things I had noticed was God
consistently describes creation as good
right well rates light it's good he
creates dark it's good
laughter he creates things in ounces
that he creates man and woman and
announces that they have dominion ya
over those things and can use them yeah
and it might be something lost the
translation but that is described as
very good as soon as that Dominion is
brought into it yes yeah it might speak
to that notion of furthering yeah great
and here's something interesting too and
we'll develop this a lot is that you see
when Adam and Eve eat the fruit
the snake gives them the fruit the first
thing that happens is their eyes are
opened okay and to me that means that
while they've woken up right there's
been an increment in their consciousness
and the next thing that happens is that
they recognize that they're naked okay
and to recognize that you're naked is to
recognize that you're vulnerable and
human beings are strange creatures it
because most animals are like this and
they're protected but not us like our
most vulnerable parts are displayed for
harm and for everyone to observe right
so we've got that sort of bipedal
self-consciousness built into us but
what's really interesting is that when
Adam and Eve realized that they're naked
it's the same moment that they know the
difference between good and evil and
that our God that just that just I just
ground away on that for years trust so
what the hell's what's going on here
what's the relationship between
consciousness knowledge of nakedness and
the knowledge of good and evil and then
I think I think I figured it out I think
I think it was that you see when you
know that you're vulnerable and they
also develop knowledge of death right so
there's deep knowledge of vulnerability
and they get embarrassed about that they
cover themselves up right so that's
culture so it's a very profound shock
for them to recognize that they're naked
it even makes Adam hide from God many
developed the knowledge of good and evil
well I think it's because you see human
beings have this peculiar capacity that
no other creature has which is I know
how I can be hurt because I'm aware of
my own limitations painfully aware and
now because I know how I can be hurt I
know how you can be hurt and I can take
advantage of that and that's I think how
evil enters the world that's what it
looks like to me it's like I got this
expansion of knowledge it says in
Genesis that that that gives people
another attribute of divinity knowing
the difference between good and evil it
has nothing to do with animals and
nothing to do with Adam and Eve prior to
having your eyes open but that the
cosmos switches when that self
consciousness manifests itself and
that's when the possibility of evil
enters the world it's something like
that and that's also echoed by the
intimate relationship between the snake
in the Garden of Eden and Satan which is
we're going to because that's what
that's a very strange associations like
this snake also becomes the adversary of
being and I think that's I'll jump very
quickly into that but I think that's
because you know there's the snake that
bites you in the jungle and then there's
the snake that lives in your enemy and
then there's the snake that lives in
your family if you if you banish the
enemy to the Netherlands and then
there's the snake that lives in you if
you remove yourself from your family and
that snake that's in you right that's
that's a that's a psychological
phenomena that's equivalent to
transcendent evil itself the thing that
inhabits every single person that's why
there's that association between the
snake and Satan and that's why I think
that people have this it's associated
with their knowledge of ulnar ability
that gives us this constant capacity for
for evil being imagine if your medieval
torturer
you know I mean people don't generally
imagine that sort of thing but but but
people were maybe evil torturers and
they were very good at what they did and
the only way that you could be a
torturers to know what would hurt you
right and so you exploit your own
vulnerable exploit the knowledge of your
own vulnerability to bring pain into the
world and I don't think that you can lay
that precisely at God's feet now people
have been arguing about that for a very
long time but but my question the
question for me that arose from that is
all right fine like tragedy you can lay
that at God's feet well if we didn't
bring additional evil into the world
could we tolerate the tragedy of being
without becoming corrupt and I think
generally the answer to that is yes
because I've seen people react quite
heroically to the arbitrary burdens of
their life but malevolence may I'm not
late that lays them low it lays them low
and it seems to be to be nothing but a
destructive force and I do believe as
well and I think you see this in the
Cain and Abel story that the root of
malevolence is the
desire for revenge against God for for
creation itself and I mean I've read
terrible things written by terrible
people trying to get to the bottom of
things and I mentioned to call them
bunny killers for example and it's clear
all you have to do is go read what they
wrote what they were doing was taking
revenge against God they knew that if it
wasn't unconscious that they've been
dwelling on this for months plotting
their revenge and it was revenge against
being itself for the crime of being so
thank you hi doctor you'd said the when
God saw that it was good you read that
as potentially well I might be better
than nothing
and the story in Genesis it's bracketed
by days which aren't necessarily literal
days young the original word you know
but it's also bracketed by and he saw it
was good you know at the end of the day
so my question is is there something
more profoundly happening there between
this profundity of speaking into
existence the way you know the start is
to this observation the seeing that it's
good and are we is God modeling
consciousness is there a little more
there for us to grapple with okay so so
more for us to grapple with in what way
in the sense that we have this amazing
this insight of speaking things forth
but you'd also comment on consciousness
as until something's observed or until
so there until it's seen so when God
sees that that creation was good is
there there's kind of this bracketing
between the bringing forth through the
spoke we you know through the word
through Jesus okay okay that's good I
see what you mean okay well I think I
think what that is is that I think okay
so it's perfectly reasonable from an
archetypal and psychological perspective
to consider the idea of the word
equivalent to the spoken truth
I mean price makes that claim in the New
Testament that he's the truth right
and embodied and so then you can
logically you can derive from that the
idea that if things are spoken into
being through truth then they're good
and so yeah I think that that
association exists and I think that
that's well I also think that that's
that's that in some sense the deepest
claim of faith I believe that because I
think that I think you have to make a
decision in your life as far as I can
tell and I think Kierkegaard knew this
more clearly than anyone else I've ever
read and that is that if being is good
then an honest relationship with being
also has to be good and then if you have
an honest relationship with being then
you're going to speak the truth and then
I think what you have to decide is that
speaking if you speak the truth then
what happens is good regardless of what
happens and that that's that that's the
rub of faith and I think that's
something that Kerry could guard
wrestled with you know and I mean I'm
trying to think if I can provide an
example about about that and anything
and easily and quickly well I guess it's
partly because it's partly because you
can live your life two ways you can you
can you can use your language to
manipulate you can use your language as
a tool to get what you want but the
problem with that is that that assumes
that you know what you want and that
you're right and that's a problem
because there's lots of things you don't
know and if you get what you want you
may find a that you didn't really want
it and be that you're not the person
that started the journey towards that
that happens a lot to people especially
when they use their language in a
manipulative way and so the alternative
seems to be and I think this is one of
the lessons for example that's laid out
in the movie Pinocchio which happens to
be a kind of archetypal favorite of mine
is but part of the act of faith so let's
say and then I wouldn't say Christian
faith necessarily I would say faith in
being itself is is the decision it's
like the decision that God is good the
decision is there's no better way to
bring better being into being than to
speak the truth and I do think that's
accurate I think that's a very wise
observation I think that's echoed in
that for
story first of all the active speech and
second the observation that the
consequence was good so yeah yeah thank
you
[Music]
good morning citizen Peterson first I
have a bunch of questions and the one
that have them answered immediately like
you have a post on Quora in which you
encourage all children to incur
skateboarding injuries but but also
stated in this post well you wrote that
do not try to rescue someone who does
not want to be rescued and be very
careful about rescuing someone who does
and can you reconcile this with what you
stated about transcendent morality and
the heroic impulse that I guess men are
supposed to be born with ok ok ok so
while the skates the skateboarding
question is I wrote I have a book coming
out in 2018 called 12 rules for life and
antidote to chaos and one of the
chapters in there is from that Korra
posting and it's called don't bother
children when they're skateboarding and
it's sort of associated with what I'd
said earlier about parkour for example
is that you know kids need to go out and
push themselves against danger because
that's what life is is pushing yourself
against danger and and when you see kids
doing things that are dangerous but
spectacular then you kind of have a
moral obligation to back the hell off
and let them experiment with their own
mortality because you can't keep them
safe the best thing you can do is make
them able and courageous and I would say
that that's a more difficult lesson
generally speaking for mothers to learn
than for fathers to learn and that was
Freud's fundamental observation but it's
it's absolutely crucial and so I've seen
kids do I mean you know you can
obviously be a fool on the skateboard
although the distinction between being a
fool and developing yourself is not as
clear as people might like to imagine
and and when kids are out there with no
helmets and doing dangerous things it's
like there's a part of me that of course
is very worried about it but there's
another part of me that admires it very
much because they're practicing what
they need to practice in order to cope
with the world ok so there's that now
the other one was risky
and evil yeah well I got this partly
from Carl Rogers you know because Rogers
was either clinician very famous
clinician and and he he was he was a
Christian missionary to begin with but
he didn't end up that way but he was
very interested in the utility of
listening as a as a means of redemption
essentially and listening by the way is
if you have someone that you know that
has a problem the best thing you can
often do is listen to them if they're
actually trying to communicate because
people configure themselves through
speech and most people can't think and I
don't mean that in a mean way I mean the
way they think is by talking and they
can't talk unless they have someone to
talk to and it's partly because they're
bouncing the idea off them and seeing if
it makes sense and seeing how the person
responds so listening is a great thing
but Rogers was also interested in the in
the preconditions for having a
redemptive relationship and that could
be a therapeutic relationship or an
intimate relationship and one of the
things he claimed was that unless the
person was aiming upward there was
nothing you could do about it
that and that seemed to be associated
with this idea of that initial choice
say between good and evil and saying
when someone comes to therapy they've
already done something they've already
said I have a problem conceivably I
could fix it and I need to do something
about it and then so half the work is
already done by the time they show up
because they've already said well things
aren't as good as they could be and I
could do something about it the question
is can you do anything about someone who
isn't at that state and my observation
and this is Rogers observation as well
is that you can't I think you can serve
by example but until the person has
decided on their own that they're wrong
that's why they're suffering if there's
something wrong about what they're doing
and that they want to fix it I don't I
think that even trying to hammer against
that often makes it worse so and I know
that Solzhenitsyn when he was talking
about the communist ideologue the really
hardcore communist ideologue that were
eaten up by the Gulag Archipelago system
you know sort of devoured by their own
he saw the same thing was that until
they were willing to admit that
something was wrong with the manner in
which they had construed the world that
it had resulted in their own demise
that there was actually no way of
communicating with them they're in kind
of an authoritarian bubble and so so I I
don't think that so even if you orient
yourself as an archetypal hero there's
no way you can get through that barriers
well I think that that's part of the
issue of free will I think that I do not
think that people can learn unless they
admit that they're wrong
there was this there's this play the
cocktail hour by TS Eliot and he has
this woman in the play and she comes up
to a psychiatrist and she says just in
the course of casual conversation she
says I really hope there's something
wrong with me and of course the
psychiatrist is a bit taken aback by
that he says well why in the world would
you hope such a thing and she says
something like well like I'm suffering
then things are not good for me I'm
having a dreadful time of it as far as I
can tell there's only two possibilities
either the world in its essence is
conspiring against me and I'm doomed
because what am I going to do about the
world like it's just built into the
structure of reality or I'm doing
something wrong so I'm really hoping
that I'm doing something wrong because
if I am then maybe I could fix it and
I'd stop suffering and it's it's
something like that and see it's also I
think that if your life isn't what it
could be and you're suffering then it
seems to me that that should be
sufficient evidence that you don't know
enough and with if that isn't sufficient
evidence that you don't know enough then
I don't know how anyone else can provide
you without evidence and so I'm going to
leave it at that
this is psychological rescue not like
the rescuing someone who's drowning for
example you can rescue people when
they're drowning even if they don't want
perfect
I'll tell you something about that
though something interesting about that
and that's relevant but you know I don't
know how many of you know how you rescue
someone who's drowning you do it like
this right you come to them like this
and you push them away with your foot if
they're I'm telling you that's what you
do if you're a lifeguard because if
they're panicking and they grab you you
both drown and that's stupid because
then you both drown right and so and
that's a really good way that's a really
good metaphor for trying to help someone
- it's like when people are in real
trouble you know some of it's they're
confused and some of it is that their
life is collapsed around them and
there's some malevolence there and
there's some desire for vengeance like
one dangerous mess and if you're going
to wait in there unprepared the
probability that they're going to take
you down
compared to you elevating them is very
very high you know because you don't
even know what your damn psychological
stability rests on you might be saying
just because you're lucky and surrounded
by sane people that doesn't mean that
you have the psychological wherewithal
to really post someone up from the
depths of the underworld especially if
they've also got one foot in hell so you
should bloody well be careful about
doing that kind of thing it's it's
hubristic to attempt it and I would you
know I would definitely caution people
very carefully about trying to rescue
someone who doesn't want to be rescued
it's it's very dangerous activity and it
can easily be counterproductive
okay so vote since 2006 I've been trying
to figure out like extract the meta the
way you've put it of social justice
warriors and I think I found it actually
they seem to have this behavior where
they just they nebulize every standard
we have so they take a standard you have
that has full of criteria they say what
something is is how it is like that's a
podium but it has these criteria within
event oh sorry
they take them they do something called
nebulization where they take something
of what and they dissolve the criteria
such that there is no way to say how it
is so you see this now with gender where
someone will say their gender but
there's no way to get logically from how
they can be that gender like how you can
be an attack helicopter or a male or a
woman or something like that
but the thing that came from this and I
figured this out when I found about you
when I learned about you is that
nebulization appears to be the exact
opposite process of individuation
philosophic the silikal version of into
it individual that rests on three
premises or three core axioms which is I
exist which is an axiom that exists in
like an objective that you exist here
and then I am which is a reiteration or
reading reincarnation of I exist which
is basically you have to say I'm right
about having existed or else it just
falls apart and you have ass which is
the question begs from that well if you
exist and you're right as what and
you're talking about God being the the
metaphor of God in Genesis being the a
metaphor for the creation of
consciousness and it appears that
individuation actually fits that triad
because if you take adds for example and
the as is a it's a predictive aspect
when you try to take the subjective and
make it object it's you have an idea you
test it in reality and time is the
ultimate arbiter that determines these
things and it changes your understanding
the reality it gets it lets you know God
it lets you know the objective and then
from that point there's the subjective
which is supposed to be form from
objective reality because you've changed
that you know have to sacrifice your old
self the old way you saw Jordan Peterson
of ten years ago was not who he is now
so it gets sacrificed and at the same
time you can point back to that guy that
Jordan Peterson and say well that guy
was wrong and that's the scapegoating of
the Sun so the subjective aspect the I
am right is the son and the holy spirit
which is supposed to lead you to God is
the ass and I don't understand the
relationship between that in the first
part okay so can you just clarify that
the social justice aspect and the
nebulization oh the social justice is
the exact opposite process of
individuation that's all it is and it
actually occurs that adds if you're a
Tad's and you're thinking about what am
I you either apply individuation you try
to apply cry so you try to find out what
you are in reality or we refuse that
paradigm and say well look I am I'm
always going to be right I'm completely
self-righteous and you stomp at that
subjective aspect where everything
becomes subjective and you ultimately
become relativistic and nihilistic so
I'm asking have you considered that the
Genesis tale and the the creation myth
and God is actually the is the process
of individuation and the Trinity is
actually those three core premises the
three axioms that come
from that okay I haven't considered that
I mean I know that young draw drew a
parallel between the idea of the passion
for example and the development of human
individuality and so there's that that
idea is lurking inside the union notion
of individuation because it has to do
with the voluntary confrontation with
mortality and also with evil right as
two of the key elements of genuine self
realization I haven't considered the
metaphorical pathway that you just
described so I can't comment on that I'd
have to think about that but I could say
that one of the things that does disturb
me about the ideological battle that's
going on right now and I think this is a
very deep part of it and this is the
part that's a battle against the logos
in in derrida's old terms right the
fellow go centric West needs to be taken
down to its essence is the refusal to
engage in precise language and I see
that in part for example manifested in
the refusal of the people who are
criticizing to ever engage me in any
debate they don't believe in debate and
they don't believe in the in the in the
let's say the redemptive power of dialog
because mostly what they believe in his
power so there's a nebulization in that
manner there's this tendency to hide
behind what's vague and fog like instead
of making things sharp and clear and
crystalline and I do think that that's
well that's part of the degeneration of
a civilization as far as I'm concerned
so so you haven't considered that then
no it would you please I'll do my best
I'll do my best
Thanks thank you okay so one this is it
one more question and make it quick okay
hi dr. Peterson my question is I know
you stated in the last lecture that the
importance for setting aims in life and
to kind of have goals to work towards
right so my question was where do you
how do you do that if you don't know
where you want to go because that's kind
of where I got stuck on you're your
future off authoring program because
yeah okay that's that's a good question
that's a really good question I think
it's the echoed to some degree in the
structure of the biblical stories and in
this manner so there's this notion in
the Old Testament that morality is
following a sequence of prohibitions
there's a bunch of bad things you
shouldn't do and then basically you're
good enough and I think there's wisdom
in that I think that's kind of where
children start right you I mean I love
children and all that but they're
they're they're crazy little creatures
and they need to be you know civilized
and partly what you do is you you lay
prohibitions on them and mostly what
you're trying to do is lay prohibitions
on them for the behaviors that if they
manifested would make their life
miserable so I have another chapter in
this book that I'm writing called don't
let your children do anything that makes
you dislike them and the idea there is
that your your job as a parent is to
help your children become the sort of
four-year-olds that adults genuinely
smile at when they come into a room
because that makes the entire social
environment both truthful and welcoming
and so your job is to make them
desirable social beings and a lot of
that is prohibition okay and there's
this ethical transformation and it
happens to some degree in the in the
tradition of the in the prophetic
tradition where there's a spirit that
seemed in some sense to rise above the
law but there's a real transformation
between the Old Testament and the New
Testament because the Old Testament is
prohibition and the New Testament is
well here's the good things you do once
you're more than merely prohibiting
yourself from from impulsive sin let's
say there's a positive good to be
accomplished well you might say well I
don't know what the positive good is
fair enough man so so this is why this
thing that I've said to people to become
this crazy internet mean but that's to
clean up your room and which which is a
lot better more useful than people think
it's a lot harder too but does the thing
the first thing you do I think and I
learned this in part from Solzhenitsyn
when he was trying to iron out his soul
when he was in the gulag because he was
trying to figure out how he got there
how he contributed to how he got there
you know not Stellan and Hitler even
though they were kind of a blade you
know but he wasn't much he could do
about that I think what you have to do
and this is part of humility is you have
to look around you within your sphere of
influence like the direct sphere of
influence and fix the things that
announce themselves as in need of repair
and those are often small things you
know and they can be like your room put
it in order because the thing is it
isn't exactly so important that your
room is in order although it is what's
important is that you learn how to
distinguish between chaos and order and
to be able to act in a manner that
produces order and in most households
there's a hundred things that could be
done to just make it less hideous and
horrible and so practicing that is it's
a real useful form of meditation and
it's also it's also I think it's a
divine act because you're taking payoffs
and you know if you pay attention even
to a room it's so interesting I learned
because I've renovated many places now
and tried to make them beautiful and one
of the things that I really learned is
that even if you own a structure unless
you've investigated all the nooks and
crannies and cleaned them up and put
your own imprint on them and made them
yours they're not yours the mere fact of
physical ownership doesn't make them
yours you have to establish a dynamic
relationship with the objects before
they're actually yours and I think you
can you can do something as simple as
just sit on your bed and think okay
there's probably like five things I
could do today so that tomorrow morning
is slightly better than this
morning was at least or at least I'm not
falling behind and those who usually be
like having to eat a toad in the morning
right it's like it's not going to be
something you want to do there'll be
things you're trying to avoid there
snakes essentially but if you ask
yourself like you're asking someone
which i think is a form of prayer if you
ask yourself instead of telling yourself
you know what is it that I could do to
set things more right today that I would
actually do it's usually some small
thing because he's not that disciplined
you know then you can go do it and then
you you put the world together a little
more when you do that and that spreads
out but you also put your you also
construct yourself into something that's
better able to call order forth from
chaos and that makes you just
incrementally stronger and then the next
day you can maybe take on a slightly
larger task and like you get the benefit
of compound interest if you do that it's
a tremendously powerful technique and
they think if you do that at some point
instead of just having to fix things up
that are not good you'll start to get a
glimmer of the positive things that you
could do you know you did the positive
things that you could do that would
actually constitute a vision and now
that's what I would recommend thank you
all right good night
[Applause]